Erst werden wir den effizienten Gas-Turbine-Kar, dann den schnelleren Jet, den unabhängigen Atom und möglicherweise den elektrospannenden Sonnen-Auto-Kar, der keine Reifen braucht. Diese spektakularen Konzeptionen werden neue Dimensionen für den amerikanischen Umgang führen.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 60. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch alle zu einer weiteren Ausgabe hier heute aufgenommen am 19. Dezember 2007. Es sind nur noch wenige Tage bis zum 24. Chaos Communication Congress, der stattfindet vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember in Berlin. Und weil der Kongress so ein Thema hat, was sich mit der Zukunft beschäftigt, habe ich mir gedacht, könnten wir das eigentlich auch mal tun und hier noch mal auf ein paar Aspekte eingehen, die der Kongress thematisch aufwirft und zwar von einem ganz anderen Blickwinkel aus. Das heißt, das Thema ist die Zukunft. Das hat man ja eingangs schon ein wenig mitbekommen oder genauer gesagt das Phänomen des Retrofuturismus. Das möchten wir hier ein wenig auseinandernehmen. Dazu habe ich mir wie immer hochkompetente Gäste eingeladen. Ich begrüße mal von links nach rechts erstmal den Gregor.
Ja hallo.
Gregor Sedlag, du warst ja schon mal auch zu einem Zukunftsthema bei Chaosradio Express zu Gast. Damals ging es um Perirodan. Habe ich es richtig ausgesprochen?
Ich sage es nicht, du wiederholst dich noch einmal.
Und ja, das war auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Einblick in diese besonders deutsche Version von Science Fiction. Jetzt haben wir ja einen Eingangston. Aber eine andere Science Fiction sozusagen, das war ein Ausschnitt aus einem Disney-Clip von 1958, wo so die Zukunft der Highways und so weiter unternommen wurde. Wie ist denn so deine Einstellung zur Zukunft?
Sah schon besser aus. Die Zukunft hat schon bessere Tage gesehen, ja.
Okay, also die Zukunft schwächelt, sagst du.
Die Zukunft schwächelt und deswegen ist der Retrofuturismus natürlich die Nostalgie der Zukunft.
Das heißt, man schaut in dem Moment, wo einfach die Zukunft als solche keine Zukunft mehr hat, besinnt man sich einfach auf die Historie.
Genau, im Sinne von schöne, gute, alte Zukunft.
So, aber das war es noch nicht, sondern wir haben auch noch einen zweiten Gast, nämlich Christian Heller. Du hast ja auch einen Bezug zur Zukunft. Du schreibst mehrere Webblogs, aber du schreibst vor allem ein Webblog, was sich mit der Zukunft auseinandersetzt, das heißt Futurplom.
Ich habe das Blog, ich glaube, seit 2005 ist es eigenständig, aber ich habe eigentlich rückimportiert, Einträge, die ich vorher noch in einem größeren Gesamtblog hatte. Ich habe auch schon vorher...
Du hast rückimportiert? Du hast die Zukunft sozusagen nachträglich verändert.
Genau, ich habe die Vergangenheit nachträglich in der Zukunft verändert.
Die Vergangenheit, die du in der Zukunft beschreibst. Was ist denn so dein Thema? Ich meine, über die Zukunft schreiben, das klingt jetzt erstmal ein bisschen...
Ich habe irgendwie vor einer Weile beim Durchklicken durch Wikipedia-Einträge, was so ein Surfen ist, wo man sehr schnell vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste kommt, habe ich mich immer mehr und mehr für diverse Zukunftsthemen interessiert oder, sagen wir, futuristische Themen. Das sind so diverse Konzepte oder vielleicht sogar, könnte man auch sagen, Ideologien, die über den Umgang mit der Zukunft oder, sagen wir, wie man bestimmte technologische oder gesellschaftliche Fortschritte für die Zukunft befördern könnte. Das sind so Sachen wie Transhumanismus, die Idee, dass man den Menschen durch Technologie, Biotechnologie beispielsweise updaten kann, sozusagen zu einer, zu einer Lebensform weiterentwickeln kann, die bestimmte Begrenzungen, die der Mensch jetzt alle leidet, nicht hat. Meinetwegen Sterblichkeit oder...
So eine Art biologisches Firmware-Update.
Genau. Und das andere, was ich ganz interessant finde, ist das Konzept der technologischen Singularität. Das ist so ein Begriff, der sehr vielfältig benutzt wird und...
Da gibt es auch so einen Vertreter.
Ray Kurzweil ist so der bekannteste. Aber es gibt auch noch andere Leute, die den Begriff auch ähnlich mitprägen. Und das ist so das... Da gibt es, wie gesagt, sehr viele Definitionen von, aber ich glaube so halbwegs einigen kann sich, glaube ich, alle Vertreter darauf, dass wir uns in einem Fortschritt der technologischen Entwicklung befinden, der auf einen Punkt zuläuft, so meinen die Vertreter relativ nahe Zukunft, in dem ein sehr, sehr umwälzender, also ein sehr großer Umschlag stattfinden wird eigentlich aller zivilisatorischer Voraussetzungen, unter denen wir jetzt leben. Was dadurch bedingt sein kann beispielsweise, dass wir künstliche Intelligenz erschaffen, die uns gleichwertig ist oder uns sofort gleich, nachdem es uns gleichwertig geworden ist, übersteigt oder dass die Technologie in einen exponentiellen, technologischen Fortschritt ein exponentielles Wachstum erfährt, der es unmöglich macht, vorauszusagen, was hinter einem bestimmten Punkt, der halt diese Singularität oder dieser Umschlagepunkt wäre, noch an Weiterentwicklung stattfinden kann. Genau, und vor allem aber auch, und das wäre halt der Bezug zum Futurismus, the end of the, vorhersagbarkeit, technologische Entwicklung, ist near, sodass wir halt, also der Begriff kommt beispielsweise auch von Science Fiction Autoren, wird er beispielsweise benutzt, um ihre Unfähigkeit zu begründen, über einen bestimmten Punkt in naher Zukunft hinauszudenken. Weil gesagt, hinter diesem Punkt muss sich automatisch dermaßen viel verändern, dass wir eigentlich nicht mehr jetzige Maßstäbe anwenden können, um darüber nachzudenken, wie dann die Zukunft sich gestalten könnte.
Die Vorhersagbarkeit der Zukunft endet. Das heißt, im Umkehrschluss bisher war die Zukunft ziemlich vorhersagbar?
Zumindest haben wir uns, also, dass die Vorhersagbarkeit der Zukunft endet, sagen wir jetzt zumindest die Vertreter der Singularität. Man kann natürlich darüber streiten, aber man kann zumindest sagen, dass sich die technologische Entwicklung bisher in einer Geschwindigkeit vollzogen hat, wo man zumindest noch relativ realistisch sagen konnte, dass in 10, 20 Jahren die Welt sich nicht so grundlegend verändert haben dürfte, wenn nicht eine große Katastrophe eintritt oder Aliens auf die Erde kommen und alles vorhandene umwerfen, während wir jetzt zumindest so die Vertreter der Singularitätslehre uns in verschiedenen technologischen Entwicklungsstadien gerade befinden, die mit exponentieller Beschleunigung dermaßen viel verändern können, dass in 10, 20 Jahren eigentlich die World as we know it total weg sein könnte durch irgendwas anderes.
Aber was ist denn jetzt anders als vor 20 Jahren? Also ich meine, was sind denn so die, gibt es, also gut, das ist ja jetzt nicht erst mal deine Meinung, sondern du beschreibst ja sozusagen nur dieses Phänomen dieser Singularianer oder wie nennen die sich? Gibt es tatsächlich?
Ja, es gibt so ein schönes Lied, I am the very model of a Singularitarian, nach diesem Gilbert & Sullivan, I am the very model of a modern Navy General.
Also das ist so, man kann auch vielleicht sagen, dass...
Singularitariana. Singularitarianisten.
Singularitaria a la Länder verneint euch, bzw. konzentriert euch auf einem einzelnen Punkt. Bitteschön. Naja, dieser Punkt steht bevor sozusagen.
Immer so 30 Jahre ist er maximal noch weg.
Klingt so ein bisschen nach Zeugen Jehovas, wenn du mich fragst.
Ja, es hat so ein religiöses Element so ein bisschen, weil es hat so was von Endzeit bzw. es kommt irgendein großes Ereignis, was quasi die Menschheit erlösen wird. Zumindest, wenn man das Ganze optimistisch wendet. Man kann auch pessimistisch sagen, an dem Tag werden die Mafien die Macht übernehmen und uns alle auslöffen und ersetzen. Erlösen von den Grenzen, der sozusagen unsere jetzige Existenz hat. Also meinetwegen, indem wir unser Bewusstsein in Mafien weiter verlagern können. Oder indem wir halt transhumanistisch gedacht unsere biologischen Grenzen überwinden. Was im Grunde eigentlich dasselbe sein kann. Und ja, das ist dann halt zumindest das Ende der menschlichen Zivilisation, wie sie bisher funktioniert hat. Diesen Gedanken. Und das hat schon irgendwie was sehr religiöses zumindest in seinen Versprechungen.
Aber du bist jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Anhänger dieser Theorie, sondern fühlst dich da eher selber als Beobachter.
Ich finde einige der Punkte ziemlich plausibel. Ich bin halt nur sehr vorsichtig, weil es in einigen Anklagen halt wirklich ein bisschen religiös klingt. Aber es hat meines Erachtens schon einige rationale Gedanken und einige Fundamente in technologischer und wissenschaftlicher Realität.
Bei diesem Transhumanismus, den du erwähnt hast, fällt mir auch ein bisschen Timothy Leary ein, der dann irgendwie mit seinem Tune-In Dropout diese Weiterentwicklung des Science aufs Leuchtenden und dann gehen wir irgendwie in den Space, dieses Smile-Konzept, Space Migration and Intelligent Life Extension. Klingt das so ein bisschen für mich die Singularität oder Transhumanismus-Geschichte?
Da bin ich nicht so vertraut mit, mit dem Konzept.
Naja, ich meine, er war da relativ einfach. Ich fasse das jetzt etwas leihenhaft zusammen. So, man soll doch einfach mal LSD ins Trinkwasser packen, dann würde sich der Rest schon von alleine erledigen. Im Wesentlichen ging es da halt sozusagen um eine drohengestützte Weiterentwicklung des Ichs, sodass man dann halt zu so einer Überwahrnehmung kommt, ausgelöst auf seinen, also basierend auf seinen Erkenntnissen, wie viel Wahrnehmung er von, was weiß ich, alles gehabt hat unter dem Einfluss von Drogen. Aber ich kenne jetzt sein Gesamtwerk nicht so, dass es nur etwas, woran mich diese Diskussion ein bisschen erinnert. Gregor, bist du denn schon mit einem dieser beiden Phänomene in Kontakt gekommen?
Ich finde den Gedanken des Transhumanismus insofern interessant, weil er schon längst begonnen hat, spätestens mit der Etablierung der juristischen Person als geschäftsfähige und adressierbare Entität in unserem bürgerlichen Gesetzrahmen. Dadurch entsteht dann natürlich seit einiger Zeit, dass wir natürlichen Personen mit den juristischen Personen auf einer bestimmten Ebene gleichgestellt sind und mit der zunehmenden Informationstechnologie und vielleicht auch einer gewissen Autonomie dieser Informationstechnologie könnte es durchaus möglich sein, dass wir in dieser Konkurrenz gegenüber den juristischen und eben auch nur noch rein juristischen Personen unterliegen. Einfach vor Gericht.
Ich glaube, der Transhumanismus, so wie ich ihn verstanden habe, zielt ein bisschen auf etwas anderes. Aber wenn du sagst juristische Personen, dann könnte man beispielsweise sagen, eine Firma ist eine juristische Person. Und vielleicht könnte man genauso gut sagen, das wäre jetzt nicht der aktuelle Entwicklung statt, aber man könnte irgendwann sagen, Maschinenbewusstsein könnte beispielsweise auch Rechte einer Person haben. Und das wäre vielleicht sogar mehr als nur einer juristischen Person. Während der Transhumanismus schon sehr darauf abzielt, den Menschen, also sagen wir mal, den Träger eines geborenen Bewusstseins in einer bestimmten physischen Hülle einfach nur seine Potenziale zu erweitern. Also sei es nun über organische Updates oder sei es halt, indem man das Bewusstsein oder halt die Prozesse im Gehirn irgendwie auf eine Maschine verlagert. Aber die Personendefinition an sich wird da, glaube ich, nicht angetastet.
Aber was ich jetzt gerade geschildert habe, könnte man in Kurzfassung, ist es der Plot von New Monster, mit dem quasi so emblematisch Cyberpunk-Genre verbunden ist, darstellen. Nämlich, dass Netzentitäten, die aber noch als juristische Personen bzw. sogar noch mit angeblich, gewissermaßen für die natürlichen Personen, noch mit Menschen verbunden sind, die es aber gar nicht mehr gibt. Also so eine Art Microsoft, wo man seit Jahren Bill Gates nicht mehr gesehen hat. Aber man denkt, dem gehört das doch noch die Firma. Aber eine vollkommen durchrationalisierte Bank z.B., die überhaupt nur noch nach Algorithmen funktioniert, kann all ihre Personen entlassen und sich nur noch durch Rechtsanwälte als Vollmachtsträger vertreten lassen, bei bestimmten Geschichten. Und unter Umständen wäre es möglich, dass so eine Firma, dass nur ein Bank ist oder ein Software oder ein Netzbetreiber, der wäre dann gewissermaßen vollkommen ohne jeden menschlichen Träger möglich. Man könnte ja auch seine eigenen Aktien zurückkaufen, das heißt, er müsste noch nicht mal natürliche Personen als Besitzer haben und man könnte den nicht mehr identifizieren und könnte nicht sagen, der hätte jetzt weniger Rechte als andere durch natürliche Menschen getragenen Institutionen. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Geschichte, die aus meiner Interpretation ist schon ein bisschen länger her, als ich gelesen habe, so hinter dem ganzen New-Monster-Ansatz steht.
Also die Führungsebene würde dann, die menschliche Führungsebene würde wegrationalisiert werden. Die Firma selbst funktioniert als Maschine. Diese Maschine hat den Anspruch, als juristische Person angesehen zu werden und entwickelt auch zumindest genug, vielleicht nicht Selbstbewusstsein, aber zumindest Eigeninteresse, um halt als Person zu agieren.
Das muss ja Profit machen.
Ja, dann ist die Unterfeilung mit der juristischen Person plausibler.
Gut, da findet man vielleicht noch einen anderen Begriff dafür, aber das ist schon mal eine interessante Vision. Die Einführung des Eigentumsrechts für juristische Personen ist ja im Prinzip schon der Sündenfall gewesen, der dann irgendwann zur Eigenständigkeit, eben auch dieser Vertretbarkeit von Rechten usw. geführt hat. Und das, was du sagst, diese Selbstständigung von juristischen Personen, das findet ja auch tatsächlich statt. Also ist die Zukunft doch voraussagbar und demnächst werden alle Unternehmen nur noch durch Computerprogramme abgelöst. Da fragt man sich natürlich, wer wechselt die Festplatten der Server? Es gibt eine andere Theorie, die besagt, dass am Ende nur noch die Systemadministratoren überleben werden.
Ich glaube, diese Zukunft hat eigentlich schon begonnen.
Das kann allerdings auch sein.
Aber zumindest im Selbstbewusstsein so mancher Systemadministrator.
Aber was, wenn das System sich selbst administrieren kann?
Tja, dann wird es wirklich schwierig.
Das wissen die schon zu verhindern.
Okay, jetzt haben wir doch schon einen sehr beschleunigten Einstieg hier in das Thema Zukunft gehabt. Und vielleicht nochmal kurz deinen Blog, wovon wir ausgegangen sind, abzuschließen. Du hast ja auch noch ein paar andere Blogs, die du noch füllst. Spielen die eine größere Rolle oder geht eigentlich alles in Zukunft?
Die haben mit Zukunft eigentlich nicht so viel zu tun. Das sind so ein Filmblog und ein Restblog, so für den ganzen Rest.
Aber in der Zukunft diskutieren, also in dem Zukunftsblog machst du ja auch Konferenz-Blogging?
Ja, also primär bisher vom Chaos-Communication-Kongress natürlich. Und ansonsten habe ich auch noch gebloggt, die Republika dieses Jahr und die Sustainable IT über Begriff Nachhaltigkeit und Informationstechnologie. Genau, Nine to Five habe ich auch, diese digitale Bohem-Konferenz.
Die gehört für dich auch zur Zukunft?
Ja, also man muss ja auch nicht immer gleich so gigantische Konzepte wie die technologische Singularität, die die Zivilisation ersetzen wird, sehen. Also man kann auch ein bisschen, ich glaube wir leben gerade in einer Zeit, in der ist eine große, man kann sozusagen die Zukunft auch von dem Jetzt erleben. Also man hat halt Bereiche, wo das Leben sich nicht groß vielleicht erweitert von vor 30 Jahren und man hat andere Bereiche, die vor fünf bis zehn Jahren in dieser Form noch nicht so denkbar wären. Und deshalb kann man auch relativ kurzfristige Entwicklungen von als futuristisch hochinteressant betrachten.
Das hier hatten wir ja schon vor kurzem in der letzten Chaosradio-Sendung, Chaosradio 130, hat sich mit dem Titel Living the Future, mit diesen Momenten, wo man so neue Technologie erfährt und das Gefühl hat, mal wieder so 5 bis 10, so Rückgefuhr bis auf Los, irgendwie so 10 Jahre nach vorne. Zumindest vom Gefühl her, auch wenn natürlich die Zeitmaschine noch nicht rattert. Hier wollen wir jetzt aber eigentlich ein bisschen mehr auf die Zukunft als solche eingehen. Ein schöner Satz, der so in den ganzen Vorbesprechungen, die wir hatten, mal gefallen ist. Die Zukunft ist auch nicht mehr das, was sie mal war. Du hast es jetzt auch schon gebracht, mit der Geschichte, die Zukunft ist nicht mehr so richtig vorhersagbar oder wird nicht mehr vorhersagbar. Und jetzt werden die ganzen Science Fiction Autoren jetzt arbeitslos? Oder was passiert als nächstes?
Ich finde, es ist eine Erschöpfung nur unserer westlichen Gesellschaft. Wenn man sich anschaut, was jetzt gerade in China und Indien passiert, dann leben die genau den Zukunftsoptimismus der 50er- und 60er-Jahre, den wir inzwischen so ein bisschen als leicht ranzigen und lustigen Hyperfuturismus verstehen. Und weil dann so Stilmittel wie komische Musik und die falschen Bilder mit reinkommen, kriegt das so einen Bias, der uns das Gefühl gibt, das ist Vergangenheit. Ich würde davor warnen. Das heißt, unsere Zukunft sieht nicht mehr so schön aus. Weltweit gesehen glaube ich, dass sehr viele Menschen die Zukunft für sich überhaupt jetzt erst entdecken.
Wie zum Beispiel China. Die bauen ja auch gleich die passenden Häuser dazu. So das, was wir, wie in diesem kurzen Clip, den wir hier schon am Anfang eingespielt haben, so unendliche Highways, Wolkenkratzer, riesige Glaskuppeln, unmögliche Architektur und wir fliegen alle mit unserem Personaltransporter durch die Gegend und der koppelt sich dann irgendwie auseinander und die Mutti fährt zum Shopping und Papa fährt ins Office und alles ist super. Ja, das heißt, hat sich eigentlich nichts verändert und wir leben nur gerade in so einer Zukunftsdepression?
Naja, ich würde sagen, man müsste sich anschauen, warum oder welche Funktion der Science Fiction so als Gattung, als Genre zugeschrieben wird. Und inwieweit sich die jeweilige Blüte dieser Gattung mit gesellschaftlichen Veränderungen und Beschleunigungsphänomenen, wie das miteinander korreliert. Und da kann man dann eigentlich eine ganz interessante Beobachtung machen, die kurzgefasst dahin lautet, Science Fiction ist ein quasi Trainingsprogramm, mit dem die Massen an die Moderne trainiert werden. Weil die Massen haben das Problem, dass Fortschritt ihnen Angst macht. Sie sind nämlich strukturkonservativ. Sie wollen letztlich, dass alles so bleibt, wie es ist. Also muss ein großes Ideologieprogramm laufen, das ihnen klar macht, nur wenn sich dauernd was verändert, dann bleibt alles gleich. Das heißt, man muss einen Weg in die Zukunft aufzeigen. Und wenn dann diese jeweiligen Milestones entsprechend der Voraussagbarkeit eingehalten werden, dann ist das quasi auch konservativ, im Sinne, dass die Deckungsgleichheit von Entwicklung mit der Vision übereinstimmt, dass man also die Vision nicht ständig revidieren muss. Und dieses Verhalten, also in den 50er-Jahren, Atomzeitalter, Weltraumzeitalter, wurde quasi so ein Teppich ausgerollt, auf dem dann die Menschen zu immer mehr Freiheit, Mobilität, Wohlstand, Konsum, Freizeit, Freizeit hingeführt werden. Und da gab es dann so ein paar Roller in diesem Teppich, und dann sind viele drüber gestolpert, und man hat dann gemerkt, das klappt nicht so recht. Und ich glaube, wir sind jetzt wiederum als westliche Gesellschaft desillusioniert. Und daraus ist dann auch so etwas entstanden, dass bestimmte Zukunftsprojekte, also Atomenergie, Atomstaat dann auch aus anderen politischen Gründen natürlich dann kritisch betrachtet worden sind. Und jetzt kommt noch ein anderer Punkt, hinsichtlich Abweichung zwischen Voraussagbarkeit der Photologen und der Konzerne und der großen Planungsstäbe, dass viele Entwicklungen nicht von ihnen vorausgesehen worden sind. Von diesen, ich würde mal sagen, von diesen Großplanern. Und zwar ist das die Welt, in der wir uns überwiegend bewegen, die Welt des Internets, die als solche wie so ein Nebenbetriebsunfall aussieht und auch von vielen aus dieser Großplanungsphäre ja anfangs überhaupt nicht verstanden worden sind. Und es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, bis heute nicht. Aber das Problem löst sich ja biologisch. Und da gibt es auch eine Enttäuschung. Aus meiner Sicht hat die Science Fiction letztlich nicht kritisch genug diese, oder hat sich sogar zum Komplizen gemacht, dieser Großplanungsvision und hat eben nicht vorausgesehen, was mit dem Internet möglich ist, was aber auch mit anderen neuen Technologien, zum Beispiel Nanotechnologie, mit der biologischen Revolution möglich ist, mit der Gentechnik. Dass diese Dinge jetzt in wenigen Jahren unser Leben dermaßen stark verändert haben, wie in einer Zeitspanne, die in der Generation von unseren Eltern noch etwa 50 Jahre umfasst hat, das ist bei uns jetzt in fünf Jahren passiert. Und diese Hyperbeschleunigung ist nochmal wieder eine neue Qualität, sodass ich fast auch der Meinung bin, es gibt eine Singularität, weil die Hyperbeschleunigung so exponentiell momentan in bestimmten Technologiebereichen nach vorne schießt, dass da auch so ein bestimmter Umschlagspunkt drohen wird. Auf jeden Fall, die Science Fiction hat quasi als Trainingsprogramm für diese Hyperbeschleunigung versagt. Und deswegen hat sie keinen Wert mehr. Und deswegen behaupte ich, dass das Science Fiction...
Also, mich hat der Anhalter durch die Galaxis ganz gut vorbereitet, muss ich sagen. Also so der Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy und die Wikipedia, das passt ganz gut zusammen.
Ist aber auch schon ein paar Jahre alt.
Was ist ein paar Jahre alt?
Nein, der Hitchhiker.
Ja, na und? Ich meine, Science Fiction muss ja zuerst da sein.
Ich glaube, das ist mehr so die Gegenbewegung. Also man hat so die Klassiv-Utopische Science Fiction, die halt großplanerisch gedacht ist und die halt sagt, wir müssen nur quasi fast in gemeinsamer gesellschaftlicher Anstrengung ein paar Großprojekte voranbringen, um die Zivilisation weiterzubringen. Und was halt korreliert mit Sachen wie Atomzeitalter beispielsweise. Und dann gab es halt eine Gegenbewegung, könnte man sagen, so einen Einbruch, der gemeint hat, dass das alles eben nicht funktioniert oder zumindest nicht zum Wohl der Menschheit funktionieren mag und was dann halt in so Sachen wie auch Cyberpunk gemündet hat, die eigentlich sehr viel präziser Zukunft wie beispielsweise das Internet vorhergesagt haben, als die großplanerischen Utopien davor.
Da will ich auch gleich nochmal einhaken, nur zu Douglas Adams. Was ist das für ein Genre, das gewissermaßen nur noch in seiner Parodie seine Berechtigung hat? Die kann sich zumindest nicht ernsthaft...
Findest du, dass es eine Parodie ist? Also ich...
Wie jede gute Parodie hat es dann natürlich...
Es ist lustig, aber es ist ja auch... Okay, du hast wahrscheinlich Recht. Es ist nicht so tief tragisch ernst, wie das vielleicht an manch andere Science Fiction-Romane sind.
Ich glaube, da muss man auch unterfallen, das ist, also wenn man das Vorge fichtlich liest, zum Beispiel bei anderen Rorges gibt es das auch, ist das, was man da vor sich hat, eine Western-Parodie oder ist das einfach nur ein Comedianto für Western? Ähnlich könnte man fragen, ist es eine Science Fiction-Parodie oder ist das Comedianto für Science Fiction?
Das ist wie der Tanz der Vampire. Auch der beste Vampirfilm, den es gibt. Aber auch eben seine Perseflage.
Ja, vielleicht muss man einfach nicht alles so ernst nehmen.
Das sowieso.
Ja, das sowieso. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, die Änderung, die sich vor langer Zeit in einem Zeitraum von 50 oder 100 Jahren vollzogen hat, findet jetzt in 5 bis 10 Jahren statt. Ob der Faktor 10 da jetzt wirklich genau der Richtige ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Das ist ja jetzt eigentlich auch so ein Ding, was der Kongress so ein bisschen aufwirft. Mit diesem Thema ist vielleicht ein bisschen falsch gesagt. Es gibt so ein bisschen diese begleitende Gestaltungsebene, das Steampunk, was ja sehr viel weniger hier ein Phänomen ist in Europa als jetzt in Amerika. Aber nichtsdestotrotz halt so die andere Revolution der Gesellschaft durch Technologie beleuchtet. Also dieser Dampfkessel, Messing-Beschlag, Optik, dieses pur mechanische, mechanisierte, was so aus dem heutigen Zeitpunkt heraus so old school wirkt, war ja nun zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt auch eben genau das, nämlich revolutionär und neu und hat die Gesellschaft nachhaltig durchgepflügt. Also wirtschaftliche Strukturen, soziale Strukturen und so weiter, die Ausbreitung der Menschheit überhaupt auf diesem Planeten, alles ist davon extrem vorangetrieben worden. Und die Steampunk ist einfach eine künstlerische Spielart, die das halt eben mit aufgreift. Aber wir haben ja jetzt dann eben genau diese Parallelität zu dieser digitalen Revolution, die eben jetzt so sichtbar wird mit dem Internet ganz konkret, die sich vorher schon ein bisschen abgezeichnet hat durch die 50-jährige Computerentwicklung, die aber spätestens natürlich mit den neuen Netzen und Kommunikationsstrukturen und vor allem eben mit Leuten, die das jetzt auch wirklich noch benutzen, dass wir das jetzt wohl ganz offensichtlich vor unserer Nase haben. Und was vorher halt die Dampfmaschine war, das ist halt jetzt der Laptop oder der Chip, sagen wir mal eher als treibendes Herz. Es werden nicht mehr die Waren und die Dinge durch die Gegend gekurvt, sondern man hat eben jetzt die Daten und die Informationen, spielen jetzt den entscheidenden Ort und schaffen halt wieder auch diese Loslösung von Zeit und Raum und Loslösung überhaupt von Orten, eine globale Kommunikation. Jetzt hatten wir ja so ein bisschen als Titel oder Untertitel, wie auch immer, eben diesen Begriff des Retrofuturismus. Den habt ihr sicherlich auch schon mal gehört. In welchem Kontext zuerst? Wisst ihr das noch?
Zuerst weiß ich nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass er mir letzter Zeit verpfergt über den Weg läuft, weil es ein sehr beliebtes Thema in diversen Blogs ist, einfach so alte futuristische Visionen in ihrer Abbildung, meinetwegen in Artikeln in populären wissenschaftlichen Zeitschriften oder so, auf ihre Realisierung im Jetzt abzuklopfen und zu sagen, vor 50 Jahren haben die gesagt, wir haben alle fliegende Autos oder fliegen mit unseren Jetpacks durch die Gegend. Und das ist ja nun irgendwie offenbar nicht so. Oder halt zu sagen, oh erstaunlicherweise haben die tatsächlich das da mal vorausgesagt. Sie haben es natürlich auf eine sehr andere Weise gedacht, als wir das jetzt tun. Aber sie haben es irgendwie von sich gedacht. Und das ist immer mehr so ein, das ist mehr so ein kulturelles Interesse, weil man sich so an den, beispielsweise an der futuristischen Ästhetik einer bestimmten Epoche sehr erfreut. Und da ist es derzeit sehr populär. Ich glaube auch so, als man findet, dass auch teilweise einfach sehr amüsant, das zu sehen. Und beispielsweise jetzt, was wir jetzt im Eingang gehört haben, so alte, meinetwegen Disney-Trickfilme, die solche Visionen an die Wand zeichnen, die wird man jetzt, glaube ich, mehr darauf abklopfen, wie belustigend diese Vision aus dem Jetzt betrachtet wirkt, als ob...
Oder auch nicht. Also ich meine, in diesem Film da, in diesem Magic Highway, war natürlich jetzt sehr auf Auto und Transport und Automatisierung von Waren hin optimiert, aber da waren halt schon so ein paar Sachen so was, wie das Auto hat, wie sie es da noch nannten, Scanned Maps, was nichts anderes als ein Navigationssystem ist und auch da auch schon so ähnlich aussieht. Das hatte ich auch bei der Chaosradio-Sendung schon mal gesagt, das passt hier wieder ganz gut. Auch ich hatte genau diesen Effekt, nämlich mit so einem James Bond-Film, wo er auch in seinem Auto einen kleinen Bildschirm hatte und blinkt, na Punkt, und du bist hier. Und ich erinnere mich halt noch gut, wie ich so wirklich dieses, ja, das geht ja gar nicht, Gefühl hatte. Also da war ich eigentlich geradezu futurverneinend. Nicht, dass ich es nicht für, also es war nicht so sehr ein geht nicht, also es wird es nie geben, sondern es war mir so ein geht jetzt nicht, kann nicht sein. Ich habe also in dem Moment einfach nicht akzeptiert, dass James Bond einfach in der Zukunft lebt, auch wenn immer alles so ein 60s Style, also eigentlich ist auch James Bond der totale Steampunk. Weil er fährt eigentlich mit dem Equipment von in 100 Jahren durch die Gegend mit seinen ganzen kleinen Maschinen und Devices und Geräten, die er immer so hat. Und dann haben wir auch wieder fliegende Autos und tauchende Autos und irgendwie mal eben auch ins Weltall, gar kein Problem. James Bond macht das irgendwie alles mal mit links, lebt aber so in unserem Jetzt oder zumindest im jeweiligen Jetzt. Er ist ja auch 50 Jahre älter geworden, aber eigentlich ist sein Abstand in die Zukunft nach wie vor minus 100.
Also Retrofuturismus, ich dachte, ich hätte diesen Begriff erfunden.
Ach wirklich? Du warst das. Na dann mal los.
Nee, ich glaube, ich habe den zwar sicherlich schon sehr, sehr früh, meines Erachtens, von den 80er Jahren gebraucht, aber ich glaube, der liegt so nah. Und ich kann das jetzt leider auch nicht durch Datenspuren nachweisen, weil das alles noch auf Papier getippt war im Science Fiction Fandom damals. Es ist aber, Retrofuturismus ist für mich, wir sollten es da jetzt nicht so überbewerten, das ist ein stilistisches Phänomen. Und so wie du zum Beispiel jetzt die James Bond Filme beschrieben hast, sie sind ja immer in ihrer Zeit überhaupt nicht nostalgisch, sondern James Bond Filme muss man ja aus ihrer Zeit sehen. Und da kommt dann auch das Problem der Lächerlichkeit aller Science Fiction, dass sie eine Kommunikationsleistung bringen muss, um einem bestimmten zeitgenössischen Publikum erklären zu können, was denn das ist, und zwar glaubhaft erklären zu können. Das heißt, bestimmte Dinge müssen so dem zeitgenössischen Stand der Technik entsprechen, damit das als solches verstanden wird. Und damit macht sich die Science Fiction zum Horst. Weil? Clarke hat gesagt, jede nur halbwegs weiterentwickelte Technologie von Magie und Zauberei nicht mehr unterscheidbar ist. Und damit kommt das Problem willig glaubhaft. Denn Science Fiction hat im Gegensatz zur Fantasy immer den Ansatz, dass die Gadgets, die magischen Kräfte und wie auch immer, immer noch auf einem bestimmten rational erfassbaren Erkenntnis- und Technikfundament basieren. Und für dieses Fundament braucht man Bausteine, die jeweils in der zeitgenössischen Publikum schon vorhanden sind. Und das sind eben die, die so am meisten altern über den Laufe der Zeit. Darüber fängt man dann an, sich zu beäumeln. Und dann kommt das schöne Bleif-Stift-Spitzer- und Bügeleisen-Phänomen bei Raumpatrouille, Raumschiff Orion hervor. Und man sieht dann solche bestimmten Unzulänglichkeiten. Und daraus wird natürlich die gesamte Geschichte, die gesamte Leistung, ein bisschen ins Lächerliche gezogen. Und das ist meines Erachtens auch ein bisschen der Grund, warum es überhaupt Steampunk gibt. Nämlich die Cyberpunk-Leute haben zwei Beobachtungen machen müssen, also die Schriftsteller, Gibson, Rudy Rucker, ich glaube Greg Beer, Bruce Stirling, das sind so ein paar der wichtigsten aus der Zeit, Mitte der 80er bis Anfang der 90er Jahre. Die haben nämlich quasi etwas sehen können, was bisher noch kein Science Fiction Autor sehen konnte. Quasi, dass in Echtzeit ihre Visionen umgesetzt werden. Und zwar, sie haben das gesehen, wo vorher immer noch eine ganze Generation dazwischen war. Gervain schreibt, wie man zum Mond fliegt. Ein kleiner Junge liest das Jahrzehnte später und sagt, das will ich auch machen. Nee, hier liest das jemand und sagt sofort, das ist jetzt die Idee, wie es überhaupt sein muss. Und das machen wir jetzt. Und zwei Jahre später haben die dann schon, das ist jetzt Cyberspace. William Gibson hat zu der Zeit noch nicht mal einen Rechner gehabt. Der hat immer noch seine alten Dings. Aber die Leute haben ihn eingeladen zu einer Technologiekonferenz, wo sie ihm gesagt haben, das war doch das, wie du dir das vorgestellt hast. Das ist doch die Matrix. Oder? Und er hat gesagt, hey, ich hab eigentlich einen Roman geschrieben. Ich bin doch kein... Das heißt, denen wurde das unheimlich. Es ging so ein bisschen wie den Leuten, die das Atom gespalten haben. Und dann kamen dann die Waffentechniker und gesagt, guck mal, so war das doch gemeint. Und aus dieser Geschichte heraus, und auch sicherlich aus der Beobachtung heraus, haben die sich Gedanken gemacht, was ist das überhaupt Fortschritt? Und daraus kommt dann auch ein Interesse an dem eigentlichen Strukturphänomen. Wenn sich dauernd was ändert, welche Konsequenzen hat das? Und daraus begann dann eine Interessensverschiebung zu sagen, okay, vielleicht auch um sich aus ein bisschen aus diesem zu aktuellen Gegenwart zu lösen, weil das einfach zu nah war. Das heißt, die Voraussage war auf einmal zu nah. Es war nicht mehr so irgendwann in ferner Zukunft. Nee, ein halbes Jahr später, und dann kommen so Verrückte und behaupten, sie hätten das alles schon umgesetzt. Das war dann nicht mehr interessant, und es hatte auch eine Verfänglichkeit. Und es hatte auch das Problem, dass mit jeder Voraussage schon ein halbes Jahr später der Lächerlichkeit preisgegeben sein mag. Das würde ein Autor auch nicht haben. Ich meine, dass nach 20 Jahren oder nach 30 Jahren man sagen kann, na, da hat er ja, aber das wenige, erkennbare 5 Jahre in der Zukunft, schon all das, was man da geschrieben hat, alle anderen zum Gähnen anregen würde, ist für einen Autor, für einen Science Fiction Autor nicht so der Brüller. Abgesehen davon, dass er sehr viel mit Marken gearbeitet hat, mit sehr vielen aktuellen Begriffen, die alle samt anachronistisch sein würden. Da ist die Vergangenheit das wesentlich stabilere Fundament gewesen, um letztlich dieselben Fragen, dieselben Konflikte, die bisher quasi in so einer Nahzukunft, Cyberpunk-Welt gespielt haben, dass man gesagt hat, aber letztlich Struktur, von der Struktur her, sind es dieselben Konflikte, die doch damals als Leute angefangen haben, so Höllenmaschinen, sich auf stählernen Gleisen zu bewegen und Fragen zu beantworten, kann ein Mensch es schaffen, mit 30 Stundenkilometer herumzufahren, wird er sich total in seinen Knochen aufgelöst und solche Dinge. Und daraus hat sich dann, weil das alles im viktorianischen Zeithalter, also einer Epoche, die ebenso stark von einer industriellen, aber so einer schwerindustriellen Revolution geprägt war, ist dann quasi der Gedanke gekommen, das schauen wir uns erstmal genau an und dann gucken wir mal, was wir da an Erkenntnissen gewinnen, um mit diesen Erkenntnissen eine Schablone zu haben für die aktuelle Gegenwart, in der wir gerade sind. Aber die ist zu nah, da sind wir zu, auch zu sehr schon Mittäter als noch Beobachter und auch kritischer Beobachter zu sein. Ich glaube, dieses Distanzproblem hat dazu...
Eine emotionale Verbindung halt auch.
Ja, aber auch so ein analytisches Problem wie in der Quantentheorie, wo man halt das Messinstrument immer gleich auch das Ergebnis beeinflusst. Du konntest einen Science Fiction Autor nicht mehr schreiben, weil automatisch jede seiner Ideen sofort von Freaks umgesetzt worden ist.
Ich glaube, es ist aber auch, man kann das auch sehr viel profaner ausdrücken. Es geht einfach um die Vermarktbarkeit. Die Erfahrung, die ich halt mache, wenn ich irgendwie mir ein Science Fiction Buch das relativ neu ist, zuliege, ist das erste, was ich mache, ist immer zu gucken, wann das Buch affin ist. Weil ich weiß, wenn das Buch irgendwie, ok, wenn es jetzt vor ein, zwei Jahren affin ist, ok, aber wenn das meinetwegen 95 gefrieben ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich schon ziemlich dated. Und das, ähnlich beispielsweise einem Science Fiction Autor, Charles Stross, der bloggt ständig in seinem Blog, dass er gerade an dem und dem Buch arbeitet und da gerade die und die Idee behandelt. Und leider, leider ist jetzt gerade das und das eingetreten, was gerade das eigentlich obsolet macht, was er eben gerade noch in seinem Konzept hatte für das Buch, was noch gar nicht fertig gefrieben ist. Und...
Das heißt, sie stehen auch wirklich in Konkurrenz mit der Gegenwart.
Das ist die Krise der Science Fiction. Dass sie von der Gegenwart überholt wird und nichts ist älter als Science Fiction, die von der Gegenwart nicht nur überholt, sondern auch wirklich lächerlich gemacht wird. Von Dingen, also mein Beispiel ist immer IPv6, hat mehr Adresszuweisung als das Universum Atome hat. So dass ich behaupte, kann man doch demnächst an jedes Molekül per so kleiner Nano-Verschränkung, an jedes Giftglas-Molekül gleich einen Herstellernachweis dranhängen, so wie ein bisschen das bei Blade Runner auf Molekularpartikel-Basis geschehen ist. Dann kannst du so ein Flugzeug mit so einem Massenspektrometer durch die Atmosphäre fliegen lassen, sammelt so eine Probe, dann wertet man das aus, und dann sagt man, schickt man BASF die Rechnung. Und sagt, guckt mal, mit 1,3% sind das eure Moleküle, die als Schadstoffeintrag da oben in der Stratosphäre laufen. Und das ist eine Zukunft, die...
Krieg ich dann auch eine Rechnung nach Hause für die von mir veratmete Luft?
Genau. Das heißt, diese Sachen, darüber können wir uns heute fast schon halb ernst drüber unterhalten. Das hat sich ein Science Fiction Autor, vielleicht außer Douglas Adams, nicht mal getraut zu denken vor 20 Jahren. Und das ist eine große Enttäuschung, weil Science Fiction muss einem einen Horizont bieten, wo man sagt, ja, das ist es. Und da will ich hin, das ist die Differenz zwischen der Zukunft, die ich hoffentlich noch erleben werde, und meiner etwas probligen Gegenwart. Aber wenn auf einmal diese Visionen nicht mehr da sind, weil ständig der Fortschritt uns da überholt, dann ist das eine extreme Krise. Und deswegen behaupte ich eben, Science Fiction ist tot.
Dann gibt es für die Science Fiction Autoren, die doch noch irgendwie ihr Geld verdienen wollen, gibt es nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ins Parodist-Diffel und dann meintet sich auch auf humorvolle Weise mit der Unrealisierbarkeit oder mit der unerwartet anders verlaufenen Realisierung mit vergangenen Utopien beschäftigen. Oder aber die Historisierung, sprich Gibson war das, das ist ein letztes Buch, das im Jahr 2007 erfiel, das im Jahr 2006 spielt. Oder Neil Stephenson, der jetzt als letzte große Erfeinung die Barock-Triologie war, die im Barock spielt. Das wären die einzigen beiden Kanäle, in denen man überzeugende Literatur als Science Fiction Autor produzieren kann. Und alles andere kann man gleich sagen, ich bin gar nicht mehr Literat, sondern ich werde gleich Entwickler bei irgendeiner Firma oder Ideengeber.
Ne falsch. Er bleibt Literat, aber streicht das Science Fiction davor. Es gibt keine Science Fiction Autoren mehr, es gibt nur noch Autoren. Und man sieht das auch als Phänomen in den Buchhandlungen. Klar gibt es noch das Genre Science Fiction. Das funktioniert letztlich auch in retrofuturistischen Kategorien, das schon altbekannte Elemente Star Wars mäßig. Das ist gegessen. Da geht es ja nicht um irgendwelche Voraussagen, sondern dass einfach nur ein bestimmtes Apparat von Gadgets immer wieder aufscheint. Das, was früher noch Science Fiction war, ist heute Mainstream-Literatur. Frank Schetzing wäre doch früher –wie heißt das da –die Tiefe oder der Ozean oder der Schwarm. Das wäre früher, noch vor 30, 40 Jahren, ein klassisches Science Fiction-Thema gewesen. Läuft heute praktisch ohne eine Bemerkung, ist das Mainstream-Literatur und der kann bei Wetten das sitzen und muss keinen mehr erklären, dass er irgendwie ein komischer Gesell ist, sondern ist ein absolut anerkanter, unproblematischer Autor, der halt über eine drohende Gefahr schreibt.
So wie es das Fernsehen auch über Nerds berichtet. Aber was ist denn mit Aliens? Ich meine, Aliens sind ja nun auch in vielen Science Fiction-Dingern drin, aber die sind nun bisher einfach noch nicht aufgetaucht. Egal, wie sehr man sie jetzt herbeischreiben wollte. Also weder ist der HG-Weltscher-Angriff vom Mars bereits Geschichte, noch sehe ich andere Kreaturen in irgendeiner Form, die unsere Fernsehsender übernommen haben. Also was denn damit?
Das ist eigentlich so die einzige noch verbleibende magische Utopie. Also man wirklich sagen kann, dass es jetzt eine mögliche, mögliche, sagen wir mal, nicht, aber sagen wir mal denkbares Ereignis in der Zukunft, über das wir eigentlich keine Voraussagen treffen können, wie es stattfinden könnte, was aber trotzdem noch denkbar ist, dass es gefehlen... Oder zweite Erde...
.könnte.
Zweite Erde. Paralleluniversum oder...
So richtig Parallelerde, das ist irgendwie so irgendwo spiegelt sich die Galaxis so auf eine ganz merkwürdige Art und Weise. Und es gibt einfach noch so eine zweite Erde, die ist nicht so exakt genauso, aber so ein bisschen so. Auch solche Themen gab's... Können wir jetzt keine Bücher nennen, ich weiß nicht, was das ist, thematisiert worden. Aber ich meine, das ist ja alles nicht da, aber das ist jetzt so weit her.
Das sind jetzt einzelne Elemente aus dem großen Fundus der Science Fiction Thematik. Aliens. Die sind aber nicht unbedingt relevant. Frank Herbert zum Beispiel hat in dem Sinne keine Aliens und hat trotzdem ein galaxienweites Universum überöffnet. Ich glaube, die einzigen Aliens sind die Würmer und vielleicht ein paar andere. Aber intelligentes Leben gibt's in seiner gesamten Galaxis nicht. Das ist alles von den Menschen besiedelt worden und trotzdem funktioniert's vollständig. Das heißt, das ist so ein Element. Ja, und in dem Moment, wo die Aliens kämen, wäre dieses Thema ja auch extrem out in Science Fiction. Dann würde sich kein Mensch mehr für Aliens interessieren.
Und kein Mensch mehr für Science Fiction?
Das interessiert sich jetzt schon keiner mehr. Ist das so?
Aber ich meine, Science Fiction-Serien, Star Trek ist nach wie vor groß.
Nein, es ist alles tot. Star Trek ist überhaupt nicht mehr da. Es gibt keinen einzigen Sender, der Star Trek zeigt.
Ja, aber es gibt andere. Es gibt einen Kampfschnergalaktiker, es gibt was weiß ich, Babylon 5, Pipa Pro.
Aber das sind so bei vielen Sachen wie... Das sind so politische Parabeln im Gewand von bestimmten... von bestimmten kulturellen Ausdrucksformen. Aber es geht da nicht so darum, wirklich spekulativ über mögliche Zukunft ernsthaft nachzudenken.
Nimm mal Science Fiction in den Computer, das hat einfach eine große nicht unbedingt eine inhaltliche Faszination, sondern das ist ein Realismusproblem. Es ist viel leichter zu behaupten, dass es jetzt eine Raumstation ist und dann sind alle Gänge gleich, dann muss man die nur einmal entwerfen und dann kann man da durchlaufen und Aliens hat auch noch niemand gesehen, das heißt, wenn die Tentakel nicht ganz richtig rumschlabbern, kann sich keiner beschweren, wenn du dasselbe Spiel Großwildjagd hast, sieht sofort jemand, dass du die Giraffe nicht richtig getwackt hast im Motion-Capture-Programm und dann fangen sie alle an zu jammern. Das fällt im gesamten Science Fiction und Fantasy-Bereich flach.
In Spielen ist so ein bisschen Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Es ist Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Aber ich würde gerne noch mal auf die Aliens zurückkommen, weil ich glaube wirklich, dass die Aliens ein Science Fiction-Thema sind, dass man sehr gesondert von dem Rest betrachten kann, weil eigentlich was man meistens unter Science Fiction versteht, ist eigentlich technologiegeschichtliche Zukunfts-Spekulation. Während ja die Kontaktaufnahme mit Aliens, auch wenn man sich vielleicht durch bestimmte technologische Fortschritte befördern könnte, sprich erweiterte Raumfahrt oder dergleichen, der seltene Fall ist, dass es zwar um etwas geht, über das man wissenschaftlich spekulieren kann, also beispielsweise kann ich darüber nachdenken, wie könnten unter bestimmten geologischen Voraussetzungen bestimmte Formen von Leben aussehen auf einem anderen Planeten. Aber das lässt sich nicht nennenswert durch technologische Fortschritte hier befördern, das Eintreten dieser Zukunft mit einer solchen Spezies in Kontakt zu treten. Und man kann auch nicht Spekulationen, also man kann natürlich jede Spekulation anstellen, aber man kann keine halbwegs plausiblen Voraussagen darüber anstellen, welche Folgen meinetwegen der Kontakt mit einer außerirdischen Spezies hätte, weil wir einfach nicht spekulieren können, zuverlässig, wie die Kultur oder die Zivilisation, wenn sie überhaupt nicht diese Begriffe anwenden lassen, einer außerirdischen Intelligenz, aber jetzt abtrennt von irgendwelchen Mikroorganismen, aussehen würde. Und das könnte sozusagen ähnlichen unvorhergesagbare Umwälzungen produzieren, wie meinetwegen der Singularitätsgedanke.
Also wie der Leitartikel in der FRZ ausschauen könnte, kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Na, das könnte aussehen, Menfheit vernichtet. Also da wurde ja fein nicht mehr fein. Oder er könnte aussehen, wir haben ein Signal bekommen, wir wissen aber nicht, was es aussagt. Oder er könnte auch sagen, wir haben eine außerirdische Rasse gefunden, die unserer erstaunlich ähnlich ist. Und die haben auch funktioniert nach denselben zivilisatorischen Voraussetzungen ungefähr. Aber es lassen sich so viele Möglichkeiten denken, wo sich derartiges Leben abweicht von unserem Leben oder sagen wir mal, die kulturelle oder zivilisatore Verausformung von derartigem Leben, dass man eigentlich jeden tiefer gehenden Kontakt mit einer solchen Spezies nicht in seinen Konsequenzen spekulativ erfassen kann.
Ich glaube, der Mensch ist so adaptiv, das wird ganz schnell eingepreist. Das wird dann sofort gesagt, Aktienkurse von Verteidigungs- und Kommunikationssystem und bestimmte Textilfasern, Raumfahrt sofort. In dem, wo Kontakt da ist, hast du sofort alle Luft- und Raumfahrtkonzerne gehen hoch. Also, die Rationalität ist auch mit dem Überraschenden kommt so schnell damit überein. Das finde ich auch gar nicht so spannend. Für mich wäre wirklich das Unspannendste insofern unspannend, weil wenn wir jetzt dieses Signal bekämen, weil einfach unsere gesamte Existenz sehr stark auf so ein Signal ausgerichtet werden würde. Sehr monothematisch für die nächste Zeit. Das wäre wie der Sputnik-Schock. Und stellt euch vor, das wäre halt nur so ein Depp, der da funken würde.
Aber du stellst deine Überlegung jetzt auf Basis dessen an, wie würde die Menschheit auf eine Nachricht reagieren, die du dir jetzt in männlichen Kategorien immer noch einteilen kannst? Aber die Idee ist ja, wenn ein Kontakt herstehen würde und sozusagen ein Austauf gegeben wäre, ein Austauf mit etwas völlig außerirdisch und unbekannt, das kann man dann die Reaktionen auf der anderen Seite vielleicht spekulieren.
Also hier wäre es wie am 9. November. Und es gäbe eine besondere Postmarke.
Ja, jetzt sind wir schon ganz tief eingetaucht hier in Science Fiction. Das ist ja eigentlich eigentlich nur so ein Nebenschauplatz der Zukunft. Da, wo sie ein bisschen nach vorne gedacht wird. Ich will jetzt nochmal ein bisschen zurückrollen zu dieser Steampunk-Geschichte. Wir hatten vorhin schon so diese nette Assoziation, dass Steampunk ja nur eine Form von Zukunftsverpankung ist. Was haben wir da noch genannt?
Stone Punk, Iron Punk, Sandal Punk, auf Wikipedia gibt es so eine ganze Liste. Einfach davon ausgehen, dass man sich mit einer bestimmten Zeitperiode rausgreift. Und eben wie das Steampunk tut, bestimmte technologische Fortschritte auf der technologischen Basis dieser Zeitperiode vordatiert. Und bei Steampunk beispielsweise wäre das dann das, was man bei den Familie Feuerstein sieht, dass eigentlich alle möglichen technologischen Fortschritte, mit denen man in den 1950er Jahren gelebt hat, von irgendwie mit relativ simplen Mechanüfen oder biomechanüfen, sprich in Verbindung mit Tieren, arbeitenden Apparate umsetzen kann.
Autos zum Beispiel, ein paar Stöcker, irgendwie ein paar Steine als Räder. Und los geht's. Ja, das ist super. Und was ist Sandalpunk?
Ähm, das, ich nehme mal an, das Sandalen-Film, Zeitalter.
Also römische, genau. Zeit.
Aha. Trigarn, tolles Comic.
Was ist das?
Es spielt immer so, das alte Rom, aber mit so Raketen und Raumgleitern. Gab's einen Comics von, wie heißt der? Lawrence?
Das alte Rom mit Raketen und Raumgleitern?
Ja, im Weltall. Aber ansonsten so in kurzen Hosen und Kurzschwert. Aber letztlich ist das nicht, finde ich, das ziemlich uninteressant, weil das Interessante an diesem Steampunk oder jetzt dem Barock-Trilogie ist auf einmal, dass die Beschreibung einer eigentlich schnarchigen Vergangenheit, die man also, ja, frühe Neuzeit oder späte Neuzeitalter der Entdeckung, geschildert wird in einer solchen Farbigkeit bei Stevenson, dass man sich sagt, da möchte ich jetzt auch sein. Das ist einfach so toll, so anders auch, wie er das beschreibt.
Wo beschreibt er das?
In seiner Barock-Trilogie. Quicksilver, Confusion, das dritte weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
System of the World.
Dass man das Gefühl hat, das ist ja mindestens so fremd wie so ein Wüstenplanet. Also, kurzes Beispiel. Man lernt überhaupt erst mal wieder, was Fortschritt, den wir schon längst eingepreist haben, für die damalige Zeit an Bedeutung und an Ungeheuerlichkeit gehabt haben mag, wenn dann so Leute aus Deutschland in die Niederlanden fahren. Und die ganze Niederlande war ein einziger großer Track, wo Leute mit Fuhrwerken auf der Straße gefahren sind. Alle Kanäle waren voller Schiffe. Und die Beschreibung, dass dort Windmühlen das gesamte Land entfluten. Das muss man sich vorstellen, als gäbe es so ein anderes Land, wo gewissermaßen 200 Atomkraftwerke, aber so alle hintereinander stehen. Eine Windmühle, das war vor 300 Jahren so, war mindestens das, was heute bei uns so ein Kraftwerk ist. So mit so einem Turm und so, da kommt Dampf raus hier, die drehen sich. Und nicht umsonst ist der Don Quixote als letzter Ritter gegen Windmühlen, weil das waren Fortschrittssymbole. Heute sieht das so, der ist ja bekloppt, der war ja wahnsinnig, der ist gegen Windmühlen angekämpft. Gegen Windmühlen heißt nicht gegen das Unmögliche, sondern gegen das Fortschrittliche, gegen das Ungeheuerliche anzutreten. Deswegen sind aber auch die Atomkraftwerke letztlich so Don Quixotenhaft.
Manchmal sollte da einfach mal ein Pferd auftauchen vor den Atomkraftwerken mit Lanz in der Hand.
Ich sage nur Steampunk letztlich, die Atomkraftwerke sind ja auch nur Dampfmaschinen. Sie werden ja nur propagandistisch verteufelt. Oder überhöht. Aber es bleiben Dampfmaschinen. Und das ist das wirklich Faszinierende, dass man versucht, was ist eigentlich das, was wandelt in der Gesellschaft und vor allen Dingen die Unterschiede, die Ungleichheit von bestimmten Lebenssituationen. Was bedeutet das an Konflikten innerhalb einer Welt? Und wir werden das bekommen, weil wir, einerseits leben wir in so einer hypermodernen, was jetzt die Informationstechnologien angeht, aber andererseits leben wir auch in so einer, kann sich mal einer hier hinstellen in Deutschland, die Politiker machen es nämlich nicht, und kann eine Vision, eine Idee geben, wie Deutschland in 20 Jahren aussieht. Können die nicht? Keiner weiß, keiner von uns kann sich das auch mal vorstellen. Haben wir dann noch Autos?
Ja, haben wir.
Fahren die noch mit Benzin? Oder nur zum Teil?
Zum Teil.
Hey, 20 Jahre, das ist das Jahr 1987.
Ey, Podcast, wir haben die Chance, also für 20 Jahre kriegen wir die Server aber durchaus noch zum Laufen. Jetzt ist unsere Chance, uns in 20 Jahren als Visionäre feiern zu lassen.
Ja gut, aber 20 Jahre, 20 Jahre zu, trotz Internet und trotz allem, 20 Jahre zurück, kommt uns nicht, letztlich dann doch nicht so ungeheuerlich vor. Also auch das Alltagsleben. Okay, die Leute haben weniger Handys.
Was Kommunikation betrifft, muss ich sagen, ist da schon echt unglaublich, was passiert.
Oder die Bandbreite der empfangbaren Fernsehstationen.
Aber das ist auch, glaube ich, ein Sonderfall. Die ganze Internetrevolution, wo man sagen kann, vor 20 Jahren hätte sich der Normalbürger nicht träumen lassen können, was er jetzt über Internet alles machen kann. Das ist, glaube ich, dieses eine Element, wo viele Leute am praktischsten erfahren, was plötzlich exponentieller Fortschritt bedeutet, der es ermöglicht, dass man plötzlich in vielen Fragen in Kategorien denkt, die vor 10 oder 20 Jahren nicht denkbar wären. In anderen Bereichen haben wir das noch nicht so stark. Bereiche, wo es in Zukunft noch gut kommen wird, oder wo es gerade ankommt, sind Biotechnologie und Nanotechnologie, die in ihren Bereichen sehr revolutionieren werden. Aber so ein Bewusstsein, dass da jetzt etwas da ist, was vor 20 Jahren noch gar nicht abzufetzen war, dass das kommen würde und wo man eben nicht sagen konnte, okay, wir können jetzt aus den jetzigen Entwicklungen das halbwegs in die nächsten 20 Jahre extrapolieren. Die Erfahrung macht, glaube ich, macht man mit dem Internet in der jetzigen Generation am allerstärksten. Gerade wenn ich jetzt den Begriff Generation einwende, hat man halt, dass man jetzt beispielsweise die Erfahrung macht, dass die Generationskluft verkleinert. Und man sozusagen sagen kann, Leute, die vor, die meinetwegen fünf Jahre älter sind, haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten mit der Generation, die fünf Jahre jünger ist, mit fritzuhalten in einigen Dingen. Wo man sagen würde, die Generationskluft, die sich zwischen den Generationen entfaltet, was die Erfahrungswelten und die Praktiken, die man beharft, betrifft, wäre halt früher, hätte halt früher viel längere Zeiträume umspannt.
Du bist ja im Prinzip diese neue Generation.
Ja, aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass es so einige Sachen gibt, wo ich gut aufpassen muss, um fürzuhalten zu können. Zum Beispiel? Na, die ganzen Web 2.0-Krams habe ich, glaube ich, jetzt so langsam ein bisschen aufgeholt. Aber so vor ein, zwei Jahren hatte ich so bei vielen Sachen, die ganzen Social Networks und so weiter, sind alles Sachen, wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, da bin ich jetzt als Letzter noch mit rein, habe ich mich als Letzter damit befestigt. Also sozusagen die MySpace-Generation.
Also es gab keine Freunde mehr übrig für dich?
Ja, ich würde halt sagen, dass, oder was bei uns jetzt allgemein ist zu sagen, so viele Leute, die E-Mail ist tot, die jungen Leute von heute kommunizieren alle nur noch über entweder Instant Messenger oder halt über ihre Social Networks. Und da war irgendwie so ein Artikel, den ich gelesen habe, der hat halt so die Altersgrenze zwischen dieser einen und dieser anderen Generation bei mir im Alter 25 gezogen. Die Leute, die über 25 sind, sind quasi von die vorhergehende Generation. Und jemand, der 20 wäre, der ist dann auch voll drinne und der ist dort von quasi einige kulturelle Praktiken, denen fünf Jahre älteren, enorm voraus.
E-Mails der Steampunk-Denten des nächsten Jahrzehnts. Du schickst noch E-Mails?
Oder Web 2.0 ist quasi die Rockmusik unserer Zeit. Das heißt, du hast da Generationen, aber ist das so wichtig? Das heißt, einerseits für eine bestimmte Generation sich identifikatorisch darzustellen, und das sind wir und das sind die anderen, ist das sicherlich wichtig. SMS-Generation und die...
Du meinst, in 20 Jahren stehen wir dann auf so einer Web 2.0-Retro-Party mit Flickr-Buttons und irgendwie...
Na, wir nicht. Wir sind ja schon ein bisschen älter.
Und auch nicht in 20 Jahren.
Wenn wir Glück haben, werden wir jetzt müssen auch eingeladen.
Das ist halt die Frage. Ich meine, wir sehen diese Hyperbeschleunigung einerseits in Bereichen, die man noch einhegen kann, im Sinne von, da geht es ja nur um Teenager-Kommunikations- und Balzverhalten. Was früher das Poesiealbum war, ist heute meine Face oder MySpace-Profil. Aber natürlich dann die durchgreifenden Veränderungen, die durch diese Prozesse durchgängig in der gesamten Industrie und in der gesamten wirklich erfahrbaren Welt passieren können. Vielleicht sind wir auch ein bisschen abgelenkt, dass wir teilweise die Fortschritte, die wir in den Bereichen, selbst wir, die uns wirklich dafür interessieren, da tauchen dann immer wieder neue Sachen auf. Ich darf mal sagen, dass ich dem Tim das Wiki mal gezeigt habe, zu einer Zeit, wo Tim das eher so als Begriff und vielleicht mal drüber geschaut hat. Aber da war ich dann ganz stolz.
Wo war denn das?
Das war im Zwischendeck auf der Seabase. Da hatte ich selber eine Projektseite mal richtig schon angelegt. Das steht für die Spielegeschichte. Genau. Du hast dir das dann mal angeguckt, weil du kanntest das bisher eher als theoretisches Konzept.
Ich wusste, dass es das gäbe, aber mir war noch nicht ganz klar, welche Power das hatte.
Genau. Jetzt war ich aber aus dem Grundgedanken raus. Bitte übernehmt.
Ich würde dir so weit recht geben, dass man nicht nur sagen kann, es geht jetzt darum, dass es allgemeine Hübebefleunigung ist. Man grenzt sich jetzt einfach ab. Die Generationen werden immer kürzer und man gehört nicht mehr dazu. Das ist nicht nur eine reine Zeitfrage oder eine Altersfrage, sondern man hat immer mehr ein Nebeneinander von immer voneinander entfernteren Entwicklungsständen. Charles Trost, den ich vorhin zitiert habe, der in seinem Blog solche Erfahrungen mit sich schreibt, war neulich in Japan und hat seinen Reisebericht als großes Science Fiction Narrativ hingefrieben. Der Argumentation folgend, dass es Orte gibt auf dem Planeten, wovon die Zukunft von in 10 Jahren gelebt wird. Wenn man das in böseren Kategorien sagt, und jetzt ein paar Jahrhunderte zurückgeht, kann man sagen, wir haben die Wilden, die auf dem Entwicklungsstand einstehen. Und wir haben die Zivilisationen, die auf einem Entwicklungsstand stehen, der sich ein paar Tausend Jahre später verortet. Sowas haben wir jetzt innerhalb dessen, was man als den größeren gemeinsamen Zivilisator-Kontext bezeichnen würde.
Genau da erkennen wir auf einmal Muster. Es geht jetzt nicht mehr um das einzelne Phänomen. Es kann nicht mehr sein, lebst du noch oder bloggst du schon? Oder bloggst du noch oder lebst du wieder? Es muss jetzt darum gehen, welche Dinge gibt es, die gewissermaßen in diesem Nebeneinander unter Umständen nach bestimmten Gesetzmäßigkeiten funktionieren. Da könnte es wirklich sein, dass die Blogger und Twitter ein bisschen wie Popper und Punker früher sind. Das wächst sich aus.
Da ist es dann interessanter zu untersuchen, wie die Entwicklungsgefichte von jugendlichen Subkulturen ist.
Unter Umständen müssen wir gucken, ob wir uns hier mit Oberflächenphänomenen zu tun haben, die wir uns zu grundlegenden Geschichten hochschreiben. Oder sind wir eigentlich gefangen in bestimmten allgemeinen, menschlichen Distriktionsgewinnstrukturen? Vielleicht kann man doch alles noch nach wie vor mit Marxistischer Theorie sehr gut analysieren. Das ist das, was für die Science Fiction interessant sein wird, wegzukommen von dem klassischen Science Fiction-Thema. So einem monokausalen Ding. Was wäre jetzt, wenn man das Teleportieren entdecken würde? Als eine geistige, ein bisschen transzendentale Meditation. Ich kann fliegen. So ein Guru würde uns das wirklich lernen. Dann würden wir alle jetzt teleportieren können.
Die Jogischen Flieger.
Ja, genau. Es gibt übrigens einen ganz tollen Roman. Cyberpunk Avant la Lettre. Der ist nämlich schon aus Anfang der 60er. Avant la Lettre. Also ein Cyberpunk-Roman, bevor überhaupt das Genre erfunden ist. Kommt von Alfred Bester und der heißt Tiger Tiger. Das ist einer der tollsten. Der hat schon alles, was so ein Cyberpunk-Roman oder Genre ausmacht, schon durchdekliniert gehabt. Da war also eine bestimmte Sache, dass die Menschen gelernt hatten, jedenfalls eine bestimmte Elite gelernt hat, zu jaunten und das war zu teleportieren. Und dadurch kamen natürlich Probleme. Im Prinzip ähnlich wie zwischen E-Mail und normaler Snail-Mail, dass auf einmal unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten, aber auch Sicherheitsprobleme, die Typen sind überall aufgepoppt, wo sie nicht aufpoppen sollten und diese Geschichten. Also dass man weggeht von so einer monokausalen Geschichte, die einem sich anschaut, weil das hat die Science Fiction sehr gut gekonnt, irgendein Gadget zu erfinden und zu sagen, was hat das für eine Auszeitmaschine. Was bedeutet das hin zu der Struktur? Wenn sich bestimmte Dinge in der Technik ändern, was bleibt dann trotzdem, weil es nach wie vor den Menschen gibt? Wenn es den Menschen noch gibt, um nochmal zu deinem Eingangsding mit dem Transhumanismus zurückzukehren. Das ist glaube ich die interessanteste Frage. Wird es den Menschen geben? Die Science Fiction hätte eigentlich jetzt überhaupt eine große Aufgabe, aber ich behaupte, sie sind noch zu sehr in ihren Gadgets aus ihrer Liebhaberei. So Sammler, die basteln wie so an der kleinen Eisenbahn. So schöne kleine neue Gadgets. Aber sie haben nicht mehr das Big Picture vor Augen.
Was du geführt hast mit dem Beamen beispielsweise, da müsste man dann differenzieren zwischen Science Fiction, die sich so in einem linearen Weiterentwickeln von technologischen Möglichkeiten begreift, und Science Fiction, die einfach sagt, wir denken uns jetzt einfach mal, wenn das und das möglich wäre, welche Auswirkungen hätte das dann auf das Leben? Wenn ich das auch als Science Fiction rechne, komme ich beispielsweise auch dazu, so Autoren wie beispielsweise, und jetzt feitere ich bestimmt an der Aufprache des Namens Roger-Louis Borges, der in einer Gefichte wie die Bibliothek von Babel oder auch in einer Gefichte wie Tlön-Ukbar-Orbis-Tertius so, denke ich, eine Menge Prozesse vorweggenommen haben, die jetzt unter Voraussetzungen der digitalen Revolution oder dem Internet in großem Maße aktuell werden. Die könnten vielleicht ein bisschen schneller sein, vielleicht sind sie auch größer, aber da wäre beispielsweise nie auf den Gedanken gekommen, dass da jetzt irgendwie immer die jetzt alle zu einem Massenkommunikationsmittel machen könnte.
Aber genau an dem Punkt ist, die Science Fiction hat ihre historische Aufgabe erfüllt, weil sie aus einem subkulturellen, sie hat quasi was im offiziellen Mainstream nicht denkbar war, was aber wichtig war, dass es gesagt worden ist, sagen können. Und das war auch ihr Problem, weil es natürlich immer so in dieser Palp-Ära mit lief. Und jetzt ist es einfach, nicht einfach, sondern es ist jetzt, was früher Science Fiction ist, ist heute Philosophie, Soziologie, Technikwissenschaft, Technikfolgenabschätzung, all das, was früher wirklich spinnert war und abgetragen werden konnte, sind jetzt wirklich drängende Geschichten, weil Klimawandel, so eine Doomsday-Atmosphäre, ist ein klassisches JG. Ballard-Thema. Und im letzten Jahr war es ja wirklich so, als ob man gefühlt hätte, dass jemand quasi den Grasherd antritt und es wird jeden Tag wärmer. Gibt es ja wunderbare Sachen von Ballard, wo er die Alpssummer durchgespielt hat, es fängt immer an zu regnen und ein Wüstensturm kommt aus, es wird nicht mehr auf und was passiert dann mit den Menschen. Also das ist, was dieses Trainingsprogramm im Sinne von Science Fiction, das waren wie so zwei Stützräder. Wir haben jetzt gelernt, Fahrrad zu fahren. Und jetzt gucken wir so ganz niedlich, ach so war das früher, als wir noch nicht Fahrradfahren lernen konnten. Jetzt gucken wir auf die Stützräder und das ist so Retrofuturismus.
Aber das ist was, was du findest, ist ja Science Fiction meistens im Rahmen eines technologie-gefichtlichen Entwicklungsprojektes. Vielleicht kann man den Begriff Science Fiction auch umwandeln, in dem man sagt, es geht um Spekulationen oder auf Basis von Wissenschaft. Und da muss man sich ja nicht unbedingt auf Technologie-Geschichte oder technologische Entwicklungen beschränken. Man kann meinetwegen auf Basis von Linguistik oder von Soziologie oder Philosophie...
Aber es gibt keinen Zwang mehr, das Genre als Genre zu begreifen, weil die Fragen sind so evident, dass sie die eigentlichen Schicksalsfragen und die wichtigen Erkenntnisfragen menschlichen Geistes sind. Und damit sind sie eingemeindet. Das ist wie so ein Strom, der ist jetzt quasi in den allgemeinen wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisprozess eingemündet.
Und deshalb kann Science Fiction eigentlich nur noch Literatur sein, weil das alte Bild, was man mit Science Fiction verbindet, ist Science Fiction. Das ist irgendwas, was in der Zukunft spielt. Und das ist halt nicht mehr aktuell. Wenn ich ein Buch freibe, was sich mit bestimmten Fragen wissenschaftlich auseinandersetzt, sei das nun in Form eines Romans oder eines Sachbuchs, dann habe ich es nicht mehr nötig zu sagen, okay, das könnte in 50 Jahren mal eine aktuelle Frage werden, sondern das sind alles jetzt aktuelle Fragen. Also brauche ich es auch nicht mehr mit Science Fiction Labeln.
Ihr seid ja gar nicht zu stoppen. Aber eine sehr interessante Ausführung. Vielleicht sollten wir jetzt mal, da haben wir jetzt einen Schwerpunkt die ganze Zeit auf der Science Fiction Literatur. Das ist ja auch gut und richtig so. Ich würde ganz gerne noch mal zurück zu diesem Steampunk kommen und zu dieser Auseinandersetzung mit dieser Zeit, weil das scheint ja dann schon doch von allen möglichen Varianten, die wir jetzt schon gehört haben, da bis zum Sandalen-Punk, bis zum was weiß ich, Holland baut Deiche-Punk, die attraktivste zu sein. Also diese zischende Dampfmaschine, so diese Akane, geradezu auch der Prototyp von Gerät. Also wenn es dampft und irgendwas rotiert und unseren Stößen bringt so ein Rad in Schwung, irgendwie zuckt einem da das Herz. Also mir geht es zumindest so und dieses wunderschöne Puff, Puff, Puff, keine Ahnung, vielleicht liegt das auch noch da dran, dass wir alle noch irgendwann mal mit einer Dampf-Eisenbahn gefahren sind. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich habe das mal gemacht.
Du, Gregor? Habt ihr aber noch live gesehen.
Gesehen hast du. Ich glaube, ich war sogar mal in einem Zug.
Also wirklich noch als Güterverkehr eingesetzt. Nicht als Museumszug am Wochenende.
Nein, Museumszug war es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Muss irgendwie in den 70er Jahren, kurz bevor sie irgendwie ausgeschaltet worden sein, wie auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall gibt es ja da einen extremen Hang. Es gibt auch so dieses Phänomen, haben wir ja eingangs schon erwähnt, in den USA, dass eben auch extrem viele schöne Sachen gemacht werden, was also einfach auch nice ist. Das fühlt sich einfach schick. Ich bin auch noch völlig breit von diesem schicken Steampunk-Laptop, so mit Messingbeschlag. Und dann auch diese ganze viktorianische Optik. Auch so diese Liebe zum Detail. Also was ich extrem an diesen Maschinen gemocht habe, auch an Lokomotiven an sich. Da wurde ja auch noch Technik geradezu verehrt. Also heute ist ja Technik in seltenen Fällen auch ein Kunstobjekt. Da wollen wir jetzt gar nicht das Fass aufmachen, was dem heute noch so gerecht wird. Aber es ist sicherlich Konsens. Das meiste sind hässliche graue Boxen. Und das wenigste besitzt eine Ästhetik, wo man sagen würde, ja, das ist super. Das ist jetzt auch irgendwie Ausdruck unserer Zeit. Und da steckt auch so eine intrinsische Verehrung drin. Das ist eigentlich alles nur noch Junk. Aber so die Lokomotive, da hat es gar nicht gereicht, dass die nur gezischt und gedampft hat und dass sie irgendwie schwere Lasten gemacht hat. So nein, da wurde also geradezu ein Künstler damit beschäftigt, das Ding von vorne bis hinten zu gestalten. Da mussten irgendwie alle möglichen Zwirbel und Verfeinerungen mit drin sein. Da steckt ja schon eine ganze Menge Verehrung auch drin. Ist das ein... Ist das etwas, was uns verloren gegangen ist? So diese Verehrung von Technik und Fortschritt, dass da nicht mehr so sehr viel Liebe zu sehen ist?
Na ja, ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen... Das sieht man auch an der Art, wie man beispielsweise mit Retrofuturismus umgegangen ist. Man macht sich so ein bisschen... Man weilt sich so ein bisschen abschätzig teilweise gegenüber einem Fortschrittsoptimismus früherer Zeitalter und findet also aus einer Perspektive heraus, die meinetwegen weiß, dass Atomkraft eher gefährlich ist. Und dann macht man sich lustig über die Leute, die am liebsten neben dem Vorgarten Atomkraftwerk stehen hatten in irgendwelchen 50er-Jahre-Trickfilmen. Und beziehungsweise man assoziiert mehr Gefahren und teilweise auch einfach Unangenehmes mit technologischem Fortschritt. Ja, das wäre halt die Frage, ob beispielsweise so ein Interesse für frühere Begeisterung und für Technik, ob das irgendwie so eine Rückkehr ausdrückt zu, oder zumindest eine Sympathie mit dieser Begeisterung. Die meint wegen, aus Cyberpunk heraus eher nicht so üblich gewesen wäre.
Also ich kann das nicht sehen. Was ist das denn? Das ist diese ästhetische, bis hin zum Fetisch-Charakter, der Technik heute irgendwie obsolet sei. Der hat sich halt gewandelt. Ich beschäftige mich ja sehr stark mit Fortbewegungsmitteln in allen Ausprägungsformen und sehe da, dass die Begeisterung ungebrochen ist und dass in einigen Teilbereichen überhaupt Dinge mit modernsten Technologie aus der Weltraumtechnik, beispielsweise jetzt so diese Segeliachten für den Admirals oder America's Cup, was da gemacht wird, das ist ja auch ein bisschen vergleichbar, weil Segeln ja so eine Faszination hat aus dieser Beschränkung, dass man eben nicht nur Motor anwirft. Das ist mal also so eine oldschool Technik, aber mit den modernsten zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln umsetzt. Und das hat man ja, da gibt es gerade in den Fertigungstechniken und in den zur Verfügung stehenden Materialien durch die Bank, ob sei es bei Ski, Bob, bei den Rädern, unglaubliche Entwicklungen in den letzten Jahren, wo man sich dann überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen kann, dass das mit dem, was vor 20 oder 30 Jahren da war. Da muss man aber wirklich halt eintauchen auf der reinen Ebene sieht natürlich irgendwie ein Segelboot immer aus wie ein Segelbooten und ein Fahrrad wie ein Fahrrad, ein Auto wie ein Auto, weil das schon so in einer bestimmten Weise so reife Produkte sind, die sich ausdifferenziert haben an ihrer Oberfläche. Da ist die Computer, also wenn wir jetzt quasi jetzt ein bisschen so auf dieser Computer- und Netzwerk- und Server-Ebene sind, ist vielleicht einfach auch zu jung, die Welt. Ich meine, ich finde es ja schon interessant, seit sieben Jahren werden diese Powerbooks praktisch gleich gebaut. Und ich kann mir überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen, warum ein Powerbook oder MacBook Pro jetzt noch anders aussehen soll in der Profi-Linie, wenn es nicht so ein silberner Kasten ist. Wenn die demnächst irgendwas anderes erfinden würden, dann würde ich fragen, was soll das? Für mich hat das jetzt genau den... Gerne würde ich jetzt die Auflösung von einem Blatt Papier haben, bedruckten, also mit 2400 DPI auf dem Bildschirm, gerne. Und von mir aus handgeblasene, kevlar gelagerte, superschwingende, semi-intelligente, anschlagsdynamische Tasten mit von mir aus individueller elektrischer Leitwiderstandslinie, die gewissermaßen auch sofort anhand der elektrischen Leitfähigkeit meiner Haut merken, mit welcher Temperament ich gerade jetzt anschlage, um daraus sofort so eine Moodwatch mit reinzubringen. Also, Quatsch, aber es bleibt letztlich so ein silberner Kasten, den man aufmacht. Und da bin ich also gar nicht so pessimistisch, sondern das stimmt. Also ich behaupte, diese Steampunk-Geschichte kommt einfach noch mal aus einer Analogie, die letztlich, ich bin Historiker von meiner Ausbildung her, dass man ein Gegenwartsinteresse anhand des geschichtlich bekannten Materials noch mal durchspielt und anhand der Ergebnisse, die man da ja schon vorliegen hat, was man für die Zukunft eben noch nicht hat, dass man daraus Schlüsse ziehen kann für die möglichen Entwicklungen, die in der Zukunft noch anstehen.
Ich glaube, dass warum Steampunk so attraktiv ist, verglichen jetzt mit einem hässlichen Klotz, in dem irgendwelche Daten verfoben werden, hat einfach mit der mit der Erfahrbarkeit von technologischer Wirkung und technologischen Prozess zu tun. Wenn ich sehe, wie eine mafine Mechanö, arbeitet und dabei züfft ist und dampft ist, dann kann ich das erfahren, während halt in dem grauen Klotz irgendwas passiert, was ich aber nicht sehen kann. Wenn ich mich jetzt ganz, ganz doll mit Computern befestige, habe ich zwar vielleicht ziemlich umfangreiche Ideen davon, was da ganz im kleinsten Detail passiert, aber es ist halt nichts, was mich sinnlich automatisch affiziert, es sei denn über eine Übersetzung, meinetwegen über tolle visuelle Darstellung auf einem Monitor oder vielleicht auch akustisches Nachbilden, beispielsweise von bestimmten Muffin-Geräufen, die implementiert werden in irgendwelche Gadgets, damit die Benutzung dieser Gadgets sich irgendwie natürlicher anfühlt, als einfach nur auf einen Punkt zu tippen und dann passiert irgendwas, aber ich habe kein Feedback-Gefühl dabei. Und das hat natürlich Steampunk-Technik von Hause aus eingebaut und wenn ich dann meinetwegen irgendein Glied einer solchen Muffine vergolde oder künstlich dekoriere, kann ich damit auch direkt den technischen Prozess vergolden und dekorieren und nicht nur eine mediale Abbildung dieses technischen Prozesses. Deshalb finde ich auch eigentlich so was wie ein Laptop, den man jetzt steampunkmäßig dekoriert, gar nicht so spannend, weil das ist dann halt für mich trotzdem nur eine Dekoration, aber es hat nichts mit den technischen Vorgängen zu tun, die in dem Laptop stattfinden.
Dann schon eher mit der neuen Nanotechnik, dann wirklich so eine Mikromechanik, die vielleicht tatsächlich noch eine halbwegs brauchbare Rechenleistung machen kann und die man dann auch tatsächlich beobachten kann.
So mit kleinen Nanorobotern, die durch die Faltkreise fliegen.
Wozu ist, ein mechanischer Prozess abläuft und eben nicht dieser quantenmechanische Prozess mit Elektronen und so.
Ja, das ist ja auch so das Interessante, dass so in der Nanotechnologie ja so quasi mechanische Prozesse plötzlich wieder futuristisch aufregend werden, weil man halt ganz simple mechanische Prozesse auf Nano-Ebene nachgebaut kann und damit natürlich trotzdem eine Effektivität erreicht, die jetzt mit großen materiell anfassbaren Marfinen für bestimmte Bereiche nicht möglich wäre.
Aber wie gesagt, wir leben nach wie vor im Dampfmaschinenzeitalter, deswegen ist es gar nicht so unklug, sich weiterhin mit dieser Technik auch spielerisch vertraut zu machen oder vertraut zu halten. Zweitens gibt es überhaupt gar keine alte Technik. Es gibt nur Technik, die funktioniert oder die nicht funktioniert. Es gibt einen Fortschritt nur innerhalb bestimmter ökonomischer oder auch funktionaler, dass neue Dinge, gewissermaßen das, wofür die Technik mal gemacht worden ist, dann besser funktioniert. Aber es gibt ja Bereiche, zum Beispiel bei den mechanischen Uren, wo die alle Anfang der 70er ersetzt worden sind durch diese Quarz-Uren. Und trotzdem ist die Blütezeit der mechanischen Uhr hat vor 20 Jahren überhaupt erst richtig angefangen, weil die nämlich jetzt von ihrer Funktionskategorie irgendwie billig vor sich hinzuticken, vollkommen enthoben sind und jetzt als autonome, mechanische Kunstwerke überhaupt erst richtig gewürdigt werden. Das selbe ist mit den Pferden. Es gab noch nie so viele Reitpferde in Deutschland wie jetzt.
Ach, wirklich?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das für die Gesamtpopulation der Pferde angeht, aber für die Reitpferde, das war früher ein extremer Luxus, weil ich meine, ein Reitpferd, hör mal, also ein Pferd brauchtest du um den Acker oder sonst was, oder irgendwie Brauerei, das war ein Investitionsgut. Aber einfach spaßeshalber da herumzureiten, das konnten sich nur die Adligen leisten. Heute ist das ein Ziviladel, Hunderttausende, und wie viele kleine Mädchen mit Hanni und Nanni auf dem Ponyhof, das ist also eine Riesenbewegung, was für uns der Computer ist, das ist für die Mädchen ja die Pferde, dass...
Horsprang.
Das heißt, sobald Technik durch eine, für den Anwendungszweck der Technik, brauchbare, neue Technik obsolet gemacht wird in ihrem Funktionszusammenhang, gerät sie in einen ästhetischen Funktionszusammenhang, der sie eigentlich erst ästhetisch, kulturell attraktiv macht, was sie vorher als reines Nutzgegenstand nicht gewesen wäre.
Das würde ja dann Mr. Clark direkt widersprechen.
Na magisch nach der Clark-Definition wäre es, wenn ich nicht sehen kann, wie diese Technik funktioniert bzw. nicht verstehen kann.
Na ja, also ich habe jetzt eine Uhranzeige gesehen, da steht dann, wir kümmern uns mit höchster Präzision auch um unsere größeren Teile. Dann hast du so einen Fliegenschiss auf der anderen Seite gesehen und das war halt eines der größeren Teile. Ich glaube, die Magie bei der Ich will damit sagen, so kleine Teile, die werden heute auch mit irgendwelchen Präzisionswerkzeugen, die nur aus der Computerwelt und CNC-Fräse und möglichst mit Kohlenstoffbeschichtung drauf, damit die dann wirklich, ich glaube, da kann man echt die Bruch- oder die Kanten, nach den Atomen, richtig schön auf, wahrscheinlich noch symmetrisch aufbauen.
Standardtechnologie.
Das letztlich ist dann ja auch wiederum magisch. Das heißt, die Prinzipien, die dahinterstehen, Lasertechnik, wenn man was ausschneidet, Laser ist Quantenmechanik, das sind letztlich magische Instrumente, um vormals mechanische, grobe Elemente zusammenzufügen, dann bleiben wir weiterhin in diesem klagischen Dogma.
Das ist dann so ein Ineinandergreifen von, auch wenn du den Begriff ablehnst, alter Technologie. Das heißt, Technologie, deren Funktionsweise, in der Art, wie sie begriffen worden ist, alt ist, das heißt, schon lange, lange existiert hat, die halt nur optimiert wird, nicht in ihrem grundlegenden Funktionsweise, sondern einfach nur in ihren Rahmenbedingungen durch eine ganz neue Technologie. Und das ist vielleicht bei Steampunk, macht ja gerade quasi genau das, dass halt alte Technologie mit neuen Funktionsweisen umgekehrt kombiniert wird.
Es kommt nämlich dann trotzdem wieder Schwellen. Wenn man die überschreitet, also die alte Technologie durch die neuen Möglichkeiten überschritten wird, dass es wieder eine neue Dimension an Nutzbarkeit kommt, ist dieses Container-Frachtschiff mit dem Segel, der eben nur durch einen Computer-Stellmotor ständig auf Kurs gehalten werden kann und wo die Frachter sich 20 Prozent Treibstoffreduzierung versprechen. Da haben wir das Beispiel, Segeltechnik ist keine alte Technik, sondern sie ist, wenn sie funktioniert, einfach nur Technik.
Dass man teilweise zirkuläre Aktualitäten von Technik beobachten kann, dass eine bestimmte Technologie oder Technik eine Zeit lang gerade nützlich war, dann wurde sie immer weniger nützlich, weil irgendwas anderes, was besser konnte, dann wird sie durch einen neuen Funktions- zusammenhang plötzlich wieder ganz aktuell und dass bestimmte Sachen so richtig zirkulär immer wiederkehren.
Es gibt eine Technik-Ideologie, also es gibt sogar so eine Technik-Ideologie, wo das Moderne letztlich das Schlechtere ist, aber weil es das Moderne ist, das Bessere verdrängt. Beispiel Schallplatte gegen die erste Generation der CDs. Das war ein eingeschränktes Frequenzspektrum und es wurde einfach den Leuten gesagt, wenn ihr hört, eure Platte wäre besser, dann seid ihr Nostalgiker. Jeder, der nur halbwegs zugehört hat, hat einfach bei der Langspielplatte ein besseres Klangerlebnis gehabt. Dann wurden alle gesagt, weil du das so gewohnt bist und weil du das jetzt drauflegst, dann die Nadelklänge, deswegen, weil das andere so kalt und kühl und rational ist, wirst du das nicht mehr hören. Es gibt inzwischen eine Generation von Kindern, die nur mit den CDs oder mp3 aufgewachsen sind. Ich bin mir sicher, wenn man einen Blindtest macht und mit gutem Equipment wird man anhand auch von Leuten, die überhaupt diese nostalgischen Geschichten, die nicht mal wissen, ob das jetzt eine Platte oder eine DVD-Audio ist, die ihnen da vorgespielt wird, die ganz klar auch ein Qualitätsranking machen kann. Wo die Platte besser abschneidet als diese Kompressionsverfahren.
Aber gerade das ist ja ein Beispiel dafür, dass es eben sozusagen nicht rein darum geht, Technologie ist etwas, was sich linear von Zustand 1 zu einem viel besseren Zustand entwickelt, sondern dass es mehr abhängt von gesellschaftlichen, kulturellen, politischen Bedingungen, wie die Technologie angewendet werden soll. Und dann ist halt meinetwegen ein bestimmtes Vermarktungsmodell. Und das Vermarktungsmodell funktioniert halt über die Einführung der CD, verdrängt dadurch eine Technologie, die andere Sachen wieder für andere Zwecke bestimmt wiederum besser war. Allerdings nicht mehr so gut geeignet dafür, alle Sachen nochmal neu zu verkaufen, wie man es mit der CD tun konnte. Und das ist so ein Prozess, in dem man sich bewusst werden sollte, dass man wegkommt von der Idee, Technologie entwickelt sich immer besser und besser und macht einfach automatisch alles andere, alles Alte in allen Anwendungszusammenhängen obsolet, sondern wird halt immer sehr stark in bestimmte Richtungen, auch in ihrer Entwicklung, gelenkt. Es geht nicht immer darum, was einfach so wissenschaftlich denkbar machbar ist, sondern es geht um das, wie es angewandt wird und warum es wie angewandt wird und welchen Zielvorgaben es sozusagen angepasst wird.
Ja, und was bleibt? Das sind so ein paar Grundtechniken, Mathematik, Lesen, Schreiben und bestimmte Fertigkeiten, die man so im Team, im Wettbewerb mit Teams untereinander, sei es nun Lego-Roboter oder sei es, wer hat die schönste Dampfmaschine oder baut einen Computer aus Dampfmaschinen. Es gab ja mal auf einem Kongress einen Lego-Rechner, der da so ein paar…
Zwei plus drei gerechnet hat.
Genau. Dass eben diese Grundtechniken wichtig sind, um Problemlösungskompetenz zu bekommen und dass dann die Mittel, die dann jeweils aus dem großen Kasten, die uns die Technik und die Physik bereitstellt, den wir dann nehmen, dass man alles machen kann.
Wir haben einige Grundtechniken, die für uns zum Alltag geworden sind und von deren massiver Wirkung, die uns nicht bewusst ist, aber wo man sagen kann, wenn man jetzt eine Linie machen würde über die Menschheitsgeschichte und die gigantischsten neuen Techniken, wir dachten, so etwas wie die Mathematik, würde einen gigantischen Aufschlag machen gegen den Frage, ob jetzt Web 1.0 oder Web 2.0 bestimmte Sachen machen, die natürlich absolut minimal sind.
Super, also ich höre euch gerne zu.
Hast du noch was zu sagen, Tim?
Ja, ich habe noch was zu sagen. Aber was sollte ich jetzt hier noch moderieren? Die Sache läuft so. Allerdings, finde ich, verfangen wir uns jetzt so ein bisschen in was kann Technik leisten oder nicht. Und wollte nochmal ein zweites Mal, dieses Mal unter einem anderen Aspekt, dieses Steampunk-Geschichte aufzugreifen. Immer noch mit dieser Mission im Kopf ein paar Gedankenmodelle zu erarbeiten, wie man sich selbst ein bisschen reflektieren soll und dieses Kongressthema ein bisschen reflektieren soll. Diese Steampunk-Geschichte bringt ja jetzt, das hatten wir auch eingangs schon erwähnt, zwei Zeitalter in direktem Vergleich. Auf der einen Seite das Urdampfmaschinenalter, da wo sie einfach angefangen haben, die Zeit zu verändern. Heute sind wir halt im Dampfmaschinen-2.0-Zeitalter. Wir haben sie nach wie vor im Betrieb, aber man baut jetzt schöne Betonhüllen drumrum. Heizt sich das ein. Vor allem gibt es jetzt eine andere technische Revolution, die die Gesellschaft stärker prägt, nämlich die Digitale. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie war jetzt damals die Zeit, als die Lokomotive kam, als Transport möglich wurde, Fabriken wurden möglich, überhaupt so maschinelle Produktion von Gütern, im Prinzip auch die Geburt von Industrie im eigentlichen Sinne. Und damit einhergehen natürlich auch ein gewisser Raubbau in der Natur, aber darauf will ich jetzt nicht so sehr eingehen, sondern eher, welche Auswirkungen hat es jetzt auf die Gesellschaft gehabt und auf die Kommunikation. Und im Vergleich dazu eben jetzt die Situation seit 10, 15 Jahren mit dem Aufkommen des Internets. Ich denke, das ist eigentlich der entscheidende Punkt bei der ganzen digitalen Revolution. Die Computer vorher waren eigentlich nur so ein bisschen das Vorspiel. Die Kommunikation ist das eigentliche entscheidende, verändernde Merkmal dieser digitalen Revolution. Nicht so sehr, dass man Computer zum Rechner benutzen kann.
Aber die Idee, weswegen zum Beispiel die Logpicker immer mit Inbegriffen waren in diesem ganzen Hacker-Community, beantwortet das ja auch. Das ist für mich auch so ein bisschen dieses Steampunk-Idee generell, dass es darum geht, alert und agil zu sein, hinsichtlich von Fähigkeiten der Technik gegenüber. Und zwar Fähigkeiten, die relevant sind. In dem Moment, wo der Schnarchstaat auf einmal gemerkt hat, da gibt es so ein Ding, das nennt sich Internet, und da geschehen ja Dinge, die eigentlich in unserem bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch bisher geregelt waren, und zwar national innerhalb der Geltungsbereich, unserer Grenzen, und jetzt machen Millionen von Menschen Dinge, die dürften sie gar nicht. Und zwar von hier, von unserem Territorium aus. Wer sind wir denn, dass Leute Dinge tun, von unserem Territorium aus, die eigentlich nicht so erlaubt sind, wo wir auch jederzeit, jeden sofort...
Oder von einem anderen Territorium aus, was hier eine Auswirkung hat.
Genau. Dem müssen wir jetzt, da müssen wir jetzt was tun. Das ist letztlich diese ganze Stasi 2.0, Schäuble und sonst was. Es steht letztlich daran, dass dieser Staat versucht, aus dem Treibsand seiner Unfähigkeit wieder festen Grund für seinen Handeln, für seinen Gewaltmonopol zu erreichen und zu erlangen. Und ich finde, da hat er auch, da bin ich gegen, und da mache ich mich jetzt natürlich sehr viele Freunde, da hat er auch alles Recht zu. Das soll er auch tun. Gleichzeitig müssen wir natürlich dafür sorgen, dass er dabei nicht übertreibt. Aber gleichzeitig wird es eben wichtig, demnächst Brieftauben wieder zu züchten. Weil da ist nämlich das Kommunikationsmittel, wo dann alle Spezialisten sind und unsere Rechner infiltrieren können. Aber wo sind die klassischen Brieftaubenzüchter, die vor 50 oder 60 Jahren im Nachrichtendienst waren? Die müssen wir dann halt züchten. Und denen setzen wir dann halt einen kleinen Chip auf und können die quasi auf Google Earth gleich mit tracken. Und das ist das Thema. Das alles, also Cyberpunk ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so, jetzt machen wir was anderes, sondern Cyberpunk ist die Zukunft, weil der Staat das, wo wir bisher die Experten sind, das übernimmt der. Und die machen es richtig. Und wir werden in ein paar Nischen, gut es gibt ein paar Leute, die denken, die werden es nie schaffen, aber die werden viel Geld in die Hand nehmen und werden die Schlausten, die bisher auf dem Kongress rumkrähen, kaufen. Und dann werden die ihr Wissen in die Systeme einspeisen und bekommen dafür eine schöne Villa und ein geregeltes Auskommen und eine Rente und viel Urlaub für Familie und Kind. Und wir müssen eben sorgen, dass die alternativen Technologien, die das alles wieder untertunneln, das sind teilweise alte, unkonventionelle oder eben auch nur, dass man sich im Freien guckt, dass keine Mikro-Nano-Spion-Mikrofonsonde um einen drum herum ist.
Tote Briefkästen.
Dass man sich mal wieder unterhält von Face to Face und wie auch immer. Es wird unglaublich viele neue, wir müssen unglaublich viele neue Protokolle ausprobieren, einfach um diesen Abstand, diesen Vorsprung gegenüber den Überwachern zu behalten.
Dann steht das, steht sozusagen, der Steampunk steht dafür, dass man beim Erfinden von neuen Wegen, neuen Techniken und dergleichen vom Fetus des Digitalen wegkommt, weil man sozusagen bisher die Idee hatte, das Digitale ist eigentlich die Erlösung. Das wird eigentlich alles regeln und wir müssen nur irgendwie auf das Digitale vertrauen und dass man sich bewusst wird, dass es noch andere Wege gibt und dass wenn das Digitale zunehmend auch kontrolliert wird oder quasi in das Blickfeld des Überwachungsstages fällt, dass man dann wieder Nebenkanäle aufmachen muss.
Gut ist nur das, was funktioniert.
Das ist wirklich Retrofuturismus. So und ein echter Back to the Roots Ansatz. Ich kann das nur unterstützen, weil der Lerndeffekt ist natürlich auch dabei sehr gut. Blockpicking ist eigentlich schon fast das beste Beispiel, gerade bei den Hacker-Disziplinen, wo man eben einfach sehen kann und das Überwinden von Schlössern und so weiter. Also Physical Security jetzt mal so im weiteren Sinne. Aber eben auch so die Nachvollziehbarkeit. Ich weiß auch noch, dass der erste Computer, den ich mir so vorgestellt hatte, wo ich mir so ein Blatt Papier genommen habe, da war das auch sehr wichtig, dass ich mir das alles zeichnen konnte und wie so einen mechanischen, also der binäre Adira in dem Computer, den habe ich halt einfach so lange gemalt, bis ich ihn mir quasi mechanisch vorstellen konnte, wo die ganze Zeit irgendwelche kleinen Kügelchen in irgendwelche anderen Löcherchen reinfielen. Auf ChaosTV gibt es auch so ein schönes Video, wo jemand so einen mechanischen Rechner gebaut hat. Also genau das gleiche, glaube ich, das Prinzip. Die Nummer habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf, aber der Link ist, wie übrigens auch alle anderen Links, und auch das muss an dieser Stelle mal erwähnt werden, immer sehr sorgfältig auf der begleitenden Seite zu diesem Podcast erhalten und auch in der Datei selbst. Bevor ihr also eine E-Mail schreibt, so etwas kommt immer mal wieder vor mit, ja, ihr habt ja das und das erwähnt, der Link ist wahrscheinlich schon längst da. Und wenn nicht, dann schickt uns einen. Ja, finde ich toll, um jetzt mal den Nebensatz gleich wieder beiseite zu fegen. Und du hast recht, Gregor.
Und jetzt voll da voraus?
Aber ich fand es jetzt ganz interessant, dass du so ein Überwachungs-Ding hast, wo uns der letzte Chaosradio Express Podcast hat genauso zwei Aspekte, die du hier schon aufgebracht hast, ohne dass du das jetzt wusstest, weil der ist ja noch zu diesem Zeitpunkt gar nicht veröffentlicht. Da habe ich ja ein Gespräch mit Sandro, der ja selber Technikphilosoph ist, wo es genau um Technikfolgenabschätzung usw. im Kontext von Überwachung geht. Das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht so sehr eröffnen, in diesem Blickwinkel, dass es jetzt das Rüstzeug ist, um sich jetzt gegen die neuen Bedrohungen seitens des Staates oder anderer drei-buchstabigen Organisationen zu wehren. Sondern was ist eigentlich so die Lehre für die Gesellschaft da draus? Also viele Leute sind ja übermant und überrollt von der Intensität der digitalen Revolution. Und das wird uns sicherlich auch noch irgendwo so gehen. Ich habe auch so ein bisschen so den Bonus, die Gnade der frühen Indoktrination, würde ich das mal nennen, dadurch, dass ich einfach selber das schon einfach mal toll fand, wie man eben so als Kind irgendwelche Sachen toll fand. Bei mir waren es halt irgendwie keine Bagger und Züge, sondern es war halt einfach alles Digitale. Ich habe mich dann auch relativ lange in diesen digitalen Glauben fallen lassen, wo ich immer gedacht habe, alles müsste eigentlich immer besser sein, wenn es digital ist. Da habe ich schon mehrere Male eine blutige Nase geholt, zuletzt hier beim Podcasting. Kann ich sagen, digitale Audiointerfaces, ein ganz großer Sack. Und diese Rückbesinnung aufs Analoge ist an vielen Stellen bitter nötig. Aber was ist jetzt sozusagen die Lehre, die man daraus ziehen kann für die heutige Marschrichtung, die die digitale Revolution angenommen hat? Damals sind die Leute eben von der mechanischen Revolution überfahren worden. Und sicherlich hätte man das ein oder andere verhindern können, wenn man auch nur im Ansatz die Auswirkungen erfasst hätte. Was sind die Parallelen, die vielleicht heute da greifen könnten?
Na ja, es ist ja bei der industriellen Revolution, kommt man ja sehr schnell, wenn man die Tragweite untersuchen möchte, das Marxistisch zu lesen, also Produktionsmittel wurden revolutioniert und dadurch hat sich gesellschaftlich ziemlich viel in der Folge abgespielt. Du hattest vorhin gesagt, dass beim Digitalen das Interessante mehr ist, dass sich die Kommunikation gewisserweise revolutioniert hat. Darüber revolutionieren sich natürlich auch in vielen Sachen die Kommunikationsmittel. Also meinejenigen Produktionen, wie sie jetzt im Web 2.0 abläuft, durch Massenkooperation, aber andererseits auch dadurch, dass viele kulturelle Erzeugnisse sich jetzt ohne größeren, mafinellen Aufwand herstellen lassen. Also in diesen Kategorien könnte man überlegen, wenn sich jetzt die Kommunikation und die Produktion revolutioniert. Und ich glaube, das ist ganz interessant, dass bei der industriellen Revolution sich die Kommunikation zumindest nicht in der Tragweite, glaube ich, revolutioniert hat. Auch wenn man natürlich so Sachen mit reinrechnen kann, wie der Telegraf oder dergleichen. Wie das jetzt passiert für die Gesamtheit der Menschen. Also für meine eigene Erfahrung, wenn ich mit anderen Menschen kommuniziere, kommuniziere ich das jetzt auf ganz, ganz andere Weisen, als ich das vor der digitalen Revolution getan hätte. Und insofern kann es in sehr vielen Bereichen natürlich noch große Tragweite haben, weil natürlich die Kommunikationswürfe von den Menschen ein Grundmaffinteil der Zivilisation ist, in der wir leben. Und wenn dieses Maffinteil gleich mehrere Sprünge vorwärts macht, oder vielleicht vorwärts ist vielleicht der falsche Ausdruck, in eine neue Richtung macht, kann das vielleicht für grundlegende Fragen, wie beispielsweise Transhumanismus, was macht den Menschen aus, aber auch so Fragen wie beispielsweise, wie werden Sachen ausgeformt wie Privatsphäre, Individualität, solche Fragen können dann eigentlich dadurch revolutioniert werden, glaube ich. Und das hat glaube ich dann auch die digitale Revolution fast von der industriellen so ein bisschen voraus.
Also man kann keine direkten Lehren daraus ziehen?
Man kann überlegen, was bedeutet die industrielle Revolution und wie hat sich das sozusagen abgespielt, dass dort bestimmte technologische Entwicklungen auf die Gesellschaft rückgewirkt haben, in welchem Maße sie das getan haben und in welchen Bahnen haben sie das getan, also durch welche Kanäle mussten sie durch. Und dann könnte man überlegen, kann man Analogien ziehen bei der digitalen Revolution. Also kann man meinetwegen sagen, dass bei der industriellen Revolution war es beispielsweise sehr spannend, dass die Massenkooperation bei Arbeit, also die Arbeitsteilung ganz völlig neue Qualitäten erfahren hat. Und dasselbe wird jetzt dem Web 2.0 nachgesagt, dass das Zusammenwirken von ganz, ganz vielen Menschen eine ganz neue Qualität erreicht. Und dass auch fraglos eine sehr andere Qualität ist, als das Arbeiten in der Fabrik war, weil es sozusagen dezentral ist und durch Heterogenität aufblüht, anstatt durch Homogenität. Dass da in bestimmten Sachen vielleicht ähnliche Bahnen ausgewählt werden, allerdings diese Bahnen mit anderen Variablen jetzt gefüllt werden. Und was passiert, wenn anstatt der Variable die Variable genommen wird? Wie ändert sich dann sozusagen die restlichen, also die restlichen Mafine, welche Mafienteile werden dann neu gelenkt oder in eine neue Position verfrachtet?
Es ist ja ein neues System, dass wir auch wirklich live in seiner Entwicklung miterleben können. Und das ist ja auch faszinierend, aber vielleicht überschätzen wir es auch ein wenig. Mal als Beispiel, die heutige Welt minus Internet oder die heutige Welt minus Geld. Und zwar Geld im Sinne, wie Geld seit 1700 verwandt wird. Vielleicht seit 1600. Was würde unsere Welt wohl stärker verändern, wenn man diesen Teil, dieses Subsystem, dass wir nutzen, wenn das weg wäre? Es gibt ja noch andere Subsysteme, zum Beispiel ein juristisches, wir hatten ja am Anfang mal drüber gesprochen, das bindet uns ja auch in ganz, ganz viele Abhängigkeitsverhältnisse, denen wir uns tagtäglich nur im Schadensfalle oder im Konfliktfalle gewahr werden, was alles passiert und in welcher Weise. Jede Fahrgemeinschaft, was da für Abhängigkeiten ist.
Du meinst, eigentlich hat sich gar nicht so viel geändert, außer die persönliche Situation des Individuums, und die ist eher noch schwieriger als vorher?
Nein, generell habe ich nur so eine ziemliche Einheitstheorie, die eben sagt, wir brauchen einen distanzierten Blick auf das, was da an aktueller Technik sich da auftut und aufbaut. Und wir sollten uns wirklich schauen, wie war das im Dampfmaschinenzeitalter, wo ein ähnliches Konstrukt auf einmal gekommen ist, das dann durchgängig die gesamte Arbeits- und Lebenswelt vollkommen durchgepflügt hat und als industrielle Revolution nicht nur begriffen oder verherrlicht, sondern auch als solche empfunden worden ist. Und das Gleiche, die Begeisterung, mit der die Amerikaner sich vollkommen auf das Automobil gestützt haben. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen wie jetzt hier mit Internet und E-Commerce und E-Government und E. Also das kannst du alles mit Automobil und Autokino, Drive-In und autogerechte Stadt und Parkhäuser, kannst du alles quasi, das war eine Ideologie, alles auf einen neuen Träger, alle gesellschaftlich bekannten Prozesse über einen neuen Träger laufen zu lassen. Wir haben momentan diese selbe Ideologie mit der digitalen Sphäre und das wird nicht so eine komplette Übernahme geben, sondern nur in Teilbereichen und das wird dann nicht mehr wegdenkbar sein, das ist klar. Aber es ist nicht so eine absolute uns überwölbende Sphäre, der wir uns nicht mehr aussetzen können. Also es ist immer noch wichtiger, dass wir Atemluft haben, sonst sind wir schon nach einer Minute am Ende.
Vielleicht sollte man auch davon abkommen, das Digitale zu sehen als dieses eine Ding, was jetzt irgendwie da ist. Das war vorher nicht da, sondern dass es vielleicht mehr ist als nur dieses Digitale. Dass man guckt, aus welchen technologischen Entwicklungen ist das hervorgegangen? Haben diese technologischen Entwicklungen auch noch andere Kinder gezeugt und haben diese einen ähnlichen Einfluss auf unser Leben? Und dass man sich allgemein bewusst wird, was alles, was unser Leben formt, alles Technologie ist und der Technik ist. Und dass eben das Geld das gleichermaßen ist, wie es halt eine bestimmte Mafine ist. Und das ist sozusagen Steampunk wichtig dafür, dass man sich halt rückgesehen, dass bestimmte Sachen, die man als Alltagsgegenstände begreift und die man so als relativ einfache, banale, alte Technik begreift oder wahrnimmt, dass die halt ein ähnliches revolutionäres und formendes Potenzial mit sich tragen, wie wir das halt jetzt gerade dem Digitalen zufreiben. Und das, wenn wir meinetwegen das Mechanöfe beispielsweise als Technik betrachten, das hat wahrscheinlich einen viel, viel größeren Einfluss auch jetzt noch hat auf uns als jetzt meinetwegen das Digitale, was ja quasi nur so ein Nachfahre davon ist.
Also Steampunk ist auch wirklich nur PassproToto. Ich meine, dass allein eine Normzeit eingeführt worden ist, die alle Leute in einen eingetaktet hat, ist eine Ungeheuerlichkeit gewesen, die es früher nicht gab.
Die war es aber auch wieder mit der technischen Entwicklung, der Uhr und so. Und dass man fast so ein bisschen mehr an Kulturtechniken auch denkt und nicht nur an, wir hatten ja jetzt ein tolles, mafinelles Tool, was das und das kann, was die vorherigen mafinellen Tools nicht konnten, sondern dass man immer sehr die Landschaft, die unser Leben formt, eng verwoben sieht mit Kulturtechniken, die halt sowohl entstehen, als auch rückwirken auf mafinelle Techniken.
Ja, aber Bürokratie plus Informationstechnologie, das wird ein Problem. Und das bedeutet die Rückbesinnung auf das Menschliche als ein quasi Unveräußerlichen. Und da kann man jetzt viel meckern, das steht in unserer Verfassung Gott sei Dank noch drin. Und da müssen wir uns auch darauf berufen, weil es wird entscheidende Phasen geben, wo juristische, institutionelle und bürokratische Institutionen uns herausfordern werden. Und da muss man begegnen die Würde des Menschen, sondern das war nicht die Würde der juristischen Person, die gibt es nicht. Und diese Automatisten und Rationalismen, die im Internet ja schon teilweise funktionieren, sind ein Spam-Programm, das automatisch die Google, das ständig alles neu... Irgendwann wird Google von uns verlangen, dass wir bestimmte Dinge anders strukturieren. Nicht vielleicht uns, aber Verlage. Das tun sie schon, das heißt Google Base. Genau. Sie formen schon eine Welt, die für sie maschinenlesbarer wird. Und das sind die wirklichen Herausforderungen, weil es kann dann mal ein Punkt kommen. Und in der Geschichte gab es das ja, dass Institutionen Menschen absolut überwoben haben. Im Absolutismus war es ja nicht der Fürst, Ludwig XIV., nicht als Person, dem das alles gut geschrieben worden ist, der ganze Aufwand, sondern er verkörperte den Staat. Dieses Lettar Se Moi bedeutet, ich bin nicht mehr als Mensch wichtig, sondern ich bin jetzt diese Institutionenstaat, sprich juristische Person, in der ihr alle aufgeht. Und ich bin nur so der Überrepräsentant, der das dann auch alles exekutieren kann und muss.
Dann könnte man doch beispielsweise fragen, welche wesentlichen Kulturtechniken stehen als Basis des Digitalen, beispielsweise so Sachen wie Informationstechnik, die man nicht einfach nur reduzieren kann, als auf das, was mein Computer aufpuckt, wenn ich eine Taste drücke. Und ähnlich so Sachen wie Revolution, die damit einhergehen, beispielsweise dass Bereiche der Wissenfacht auf die Simulation viel mehr als Tool zurückgreifen, als sie es früher getan haben. Sodass bestimmte Denkprozesse jetzt ganz anders strukturiert sind, als das halt prädigital üblich war. Was aber nicht unbedingt damit zu tun hat, dass wir jetzt alle Computer haben und alle das neueste Gadget haben, sondern einfach fast schon der älteren Informationstechnischen Revolution gefuldet ist, die halt von den mit den Großcomputern, die eigentlich noch eher mechanisch wahrgenommen wurden, zu tun hat als jetzt mit der Internetrevolution, in der wir uns gerade so breit machen als vermeintlich oder vielleicht wirklich gigantische Revolutionen in unserer Lebenswelt.
Wir füttern hier den Moloch. Ich meine, die Internettechnologie und die Revolution ist ja für uns deswegen so attraktiv gewesen, weil sie uns ermächtigt und nach wie vor mächtige Instrumente an die Hand gibt, die uns Dinge ermöglicht, die vorher nicht möglich waren. Bestes Beispiel dieses Google Earth, dieses Hallo, was früher nur NSA und CIA konnte, das kann ich jetzt auch. Das jeder selber produzieren kann. Wir haben immer eine individualistische Aneignung gegen bürokratische Institutionen. Was wir jetzt gerade machen, richtet sich gegen den öffentlich-rechtlichen Schnarchfunk und Großstrukturen, die früher alle noch polizeistaatlich überwacht worden sind, dass keiner mit einer kleinen Antenne herumgesendet hat. Das alles haben wir überwunden. Und gleichzeitig füttern wir, während Millionen das machen, durch die Rationalisierungsprozesse, einen eigenständigen Apparat, der uns in derselben Bewegung unheimlich viele dieser Freiheiten, die wir uns gerade erkämpft haben, schon wieder wegnehmen. Und vielleicht sollten wir versuchen, genau diese Dialektik zwischen massenhaft Vorteile zu gewinnen, die in der Summe zu Unfreiheiten und Nachteilen für alle wiederführen. Dass wir das mal als so einen Wellenprozess durch die Geschichte uns anschauen, um zu gucken, gibt es in diesem Auf und Ab zwischen Individualisierung und Totalitarismus und Bürokratisierung, gibt es da vielleicht irgendeinen Gleichgewichtszustand? Oder können wir Regeln erkennen, die es uns ermöglichen, Mensch zu bleiben und eine gewisse Grundfreiheit zu behalten?
Wobei ja auch so gerade Sachen, die man jetzt als Ende jeder Entwicklung stellen mag, wie Begriffe wie Freiheit, individuelle Freiheit versus Totalitarismus und dergleichen, dass ja auch alle Sachen sind, die sehr historisch geprägt sind. Und wo man vielleicht sagen kann, okay, in den letzten paar Jahrhunderten im Westen waren das so prägende Diskussionspunkte. Aber wenn man jetzt mal den Fokus breiter macht und nicht in den letzten paar Jahrhunderten, sondern in den letzten paar Jahrtausenden denkt und die Weltkulturkreise alle mit zusammenzieht, man feststellen muss, dass das halt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt die natürlichen, also sozusagen naturgefriebene Gesetze sind, dass der Mensch danach hinstrebt und dass das sozusagen ein ideales, natürliches Mittel gibt, auf das jetzt jede gesellschaftliche Entwicklung eigentlich sich am Ende einpendeln muss ganz automatisch.
Eine natürliche Entwicklung?
Also dass es sozusagen einen natürlichen Zustand individueller Freiheit beispielsweise gibt, auf den jetzt alles hinstreben würde automatisch, weil das einfach so im Menschen so drin ist, dass er nur unter diesen Umständen zu leben mag.
Die Frage, ob der Mensch wirklich so individuell ist.
Und ob er bleibt. Also dieses Singularitätsproblem sehe ich als durchaus drängend. Das kann uns noch in unserer Lebenszeit in eine ganz neue Welt katapultieren.
Dass wir den Begriff Mensch sowieso fragen stellen müssen.
Den Spaß hat er.
Vielleicht erleben wir das als was Gutes oder als was Schlechtes.
Dass die Systeme uns nicht mehr brauchen.
Das ist so diese Terminator-Vision. Die übernehmen dann einfach alles und werden dann einfach noch zusammengeschossen.
Oder wir werden, ganz selbstbewusst sein, wird alles geuploadet auf eine Großmorphine. Und das wird dann alles zusammenverrechnet zu einem großen Weltgeist. Und das Individuum ist obsolet geworden.
Dann hoffe ich aber, dass diese Vision des Disney-Films sich dann auch wirklich durchsetzt. Dass wir dann in dieser entstehenden Freizeit uns dann einfach nur mit schlarafoiden Tätigkeiten beschäftigen können und dann einfach nur noch Beeren zupfen.
Wir sind dann super Haustiere.
Wir denken vor allem nicht mehr in wir oder ich. Das sind alles Begriffe, die dann historisch geworden sind.
Ja, ich ziehe jetzt mal hier ein bisschen die Reißleine. Dann nehmen wir jetzt zwei Stunden durch. Ich habe den Eindruck, wir könnten jetzt noch stundenlang so weiter diskutieren, aber alles Wichtige ist, glaube ich, gesagt. Und wir haben eine schöne Antwort gefunden, was Steampunk ist. Steampunk ist Rückbesinnung. Was für ein schönes Thema für den Kongress, der immer zur Weihnachtszeit hier wieder einkehrt in Berlin. Und ja, vielen Dank für das äußerst aufgeweckte und tief intellektuelle Gespräch. Ich glaube, das war eine der tiefsten Diskussionen, die wir bei Chaosradio Express bisher geführt haben. Ich hoffe auch, dass es euch gefallen hat. Und ich sage jetzt erstmal danke, Gregor. Danke, Christian. Danke, Tim. Für die Ausführung. Ich bin heute ein bisschen angeschlagen. Ich habe einfach definitiv zu wenig geschlafen für eine überagile Moderation des Podcasts. Aber es war sehr interessant, auch euren Ausführungen mal länger zu lauschen und die Sachen einfach mal ein bisschen laufen zu lassen, denn das ist auch sehr wichtig. Ja, mir bleibt dann nur noch mich auch zu verabschieden und natürlich auf unser Blog und Wiki das Chaosradio-Portal mit all seinen Ressourcen hinzuweisen. Das wird jetzt auch einer der letzten Podcasts. Es gibt noch ein paar Videos, die wir in diesem Jahr noch machen. Einer hat, glaube ich, noch eine Chance, vielleicht vom Kongress veröffentlicht zu werden. Das werden wir sehen. Ich hab mir ja gesagt, keine Versprechen machen, weil das klappt dann sowieso immer noch nicht. Erstmal zusehen, dass ich die zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch unveröffentlichten Episoden noch raushauen kann. Auf jeden Fall geht es weiter mit Chaosradio Express. Die Liste für den Januar ist auch schon wieder gut gefüllt und ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich und bin natürlich interessiert an eurem Feedback. Schickt uns E-Mail chaosradio.ccc.de oder beteiligt euch mit Kommentaren im Blog unter blog.chaosradio.ccc.de und wenn ihr richtig viel wisst über Chaosradio oder Feedback zu den Sendungen persistent ins Web stellen wollt, dann bedient euch das Chaosradio-Wikis. So, das war der Official Blurp, den haben wir jetzt auch noch abgesetzt. Ja, nochmal in die Runde. Vielen Dank und dann sagen wir mal alle ganz brav Tschüss und ja, das war's bei Chaosradio Express.